हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल तो सबसे
पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही
है लाउड एंड
क्लियर प्लीज
बताइए ओके थैंक यू एंड वेलकम टू डेनिक्स
अकेडमी और यह सिस्टम हैकिंग का हमारा
फर्स्ट प्रैक्टिकल स्टार्ट होने वाला है
आज अपनी क्लास में हम स्टार्ट करेंगे तो
आई होप जो फंडामेंटल था आपका जो रिलेटेड
सिस्टम हैकिंग मैंने काफी अच्छे से कवर
किया होगा और आप लोगों को समझ में आ गया
होगा तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं एक से दो
मिनट का और फिर डायरेक्टली हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे अपना सीटीएफ के थ्रू लैब के थ्रू
अपना सिस्टम हैकिंग का पहला
पार्ट जो आज की वल्नरेबल है कमांड
इंजेक्शन वल्नरेबल के थ्रू हम कैसे सिस्टम
में एंटर करते और सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं
तो मुझे यह बता
दीजिए फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में आज कौन आ रहा
है कोई ऐसा स्टूडेंट जो आज फर्स्ट टाइम
आया क्लास में
ओके आई थिंक दे लॉट ऑफ स्टूडेंट्स जो आज
पहली बार क्लास अटेंड कर रहे हैं तो फाइन
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अगर आप पहली बार क्लास
को अटेंड कर रहे हैं तो उसके लिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है आपको सबसे पहले क्या करना
है अगर आप फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में आए हो तो
यह डे 17 क्लास आपकी और मिनिमम
क्लास 1.30 मिनट की होती है मतलब एक घंटा
30 मिनट की नॉर्मल टू नॉर्मल क्लास रहती
हमारी जो फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग की जो अभी
सीरीज हमारी चल रही है जिसका नाम डे
फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल सर्टिफिकेट
का नाम है तो आप लोगों को हम बता देते कि
इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन आप लोगों के लिए
यही है कि आपको सिंपली क्या करना है आपको
यहां
पर गो टू योर आपको सबसे पहले तो हमारी
चैनल है सॉरी
[संगीत]
whatsapp2 एंड रिसोर्सेस यहां पर सारे
अपडेट आपको मिलते हैं कि हमने आपके नोट्स
अपलोड कर दिए हैं या जो भी व्हाट एवर
इंफॉर्मेशन एक क्लास कब होगी या नेक्स्ट
क्लास किस चीज की होगी नेक्स्ट कोर्स कौन
सा आने वाला है सारी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर
आपके अवेलेबल रहती है तो सिंपली आपको
क्लिक करना है और व्यू चैनल यहां पर आप
क्या कर सकते हो डेफ अकेडमी
के चैनल को
whatsapp2 लिंक दिन आपको लिंक दिन पर जाना
है और लिंक दिन पर जाकर आप क्या कर सकते
हो डेनिक्स अकेडमी के पेज को सब्सक्राइब
जैसे कि ये मेरी पर्सनल आईडी है लिंक दिन
की आप चाहो तो को रिक्वेस्ट कर सकते हो और
इस पर आप अपने क्वेश्चन भी पूछ सकते हो
मैसेज में मैं रिप्लाई करता हूं नॉर्मली
यह मेरी पर्सनल पर्सनल लिडेन प्रोफाइल है
आप चाहो तो आपको क्या करना है गो टू
डेनिक्स अकेडमी तो डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
डेफ साइबर सिक्योरिटी का यह लिंक दिन पेज
है आपको सिंपली इसको क्या करना है
सब्सक्राइब करना है फॉलो करना है और यहां
पर भी आपको लेटेस्ट अपडेट्स मिलते हैं और
कुछ चीजें क्या होता है कि जब भी मैं आपको
टास्क दूंगा कोई भी लैब सॉल्व करने के लिए
दूंगा तो आपको सिंपली कहना सॉल्व करने के
बाद यहां पर हम मुझे डिफरेंस अकैडमी प्लस
मेरे को टैग करना है सो दैट कि हमें पता
रहेगा कि कितने स्टूडेंट्स कोर्स के साथ
एक्टिव है एक और चीज है अगर आपको नोट्स
चाहिए जो पीपीटी मैं आपके सामने शो करता
हूं रिप्रेजेंट करता हूं उस पीपीटी का
एक्सेस चाहिए तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
गो टू de.com आपको डेनिक्स अकैडमी पर
क्लिक करना है य fix.com और सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है गो टू अकेडमी टैब देन उसके
बाद आपको फ्री रिसोर्सेस के भी अंदर जा
सकते हो गो टू फ्री रिसोर्सेस और अभी
थोड़ा सा अपलोड होने में टाइम ले रही है
मशीन वेबसाइट
को अब्दुल पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन को बिल्कुल
डिटेल में सीखेंगे ईच एंड एवरी टेक्निक आई
विल एक्सप्लेन हर एक स्टेप को मैं जितने
भी सेवन स्टेप थे ए स्टेप का जो जिक्र
किया था मैंने वो सारी चीज मैं आपको
डिटेल्स में बताऊंगा तो आपको सिंपली यहां
पर क्या करना है डीएचसी सर्टिफिकेट नोट्स
यहां पर आप सिंपली गो टू दिस लिंक और यहां
पर आप जस्ट पे ₹1 यहां पर आपको हमारे
रिसोर्सेस प्लस में नोट्स का एक्सेस मिल
जाएगा जो क्लास के बाद अपलोड हो जाते हैं
और प्लस में आपको फायदा यह रहेगा कि यहां
पर जो सर्टिफिकेट है यह जब कोर्स कंप्लीट
हो जाएगा कंप्लीशन सर्टिफिकेट आपका मिल
जाएगा जिसको आप यूज़ कर सकते हो तो इसका
बेनिफिट यही है जस्ट पे ₹1 और यहां पर
आपके पास कोर्सेज और इनका बेनिफिट मिलेगा
सर्टिफिकेट प्लस में रिसोर्सेस का बेनिफिट
रहेगा यह चीज जो मैं आपको बताना चाहता था
मैंने आपको बता दिया जो न्यू कमर्स है जो
फर्स्ट टाइम आए हैं हमारी क्लास में आज की
क्लास में ओके जो पुराने हैं उनको पहले से
पता है और आज जल्दी हम टॉपिक को स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं अभी ओके और अभी हम चलते हैं
यह रहा अभी मैं देख लेता हूं कि किसी कोई
क्यूरी है
तो यस लाइफ टाइम एक्सेस रहेगा आपका और
जितना कंप्लीट कोर्स में पढ़ाने वाला हूं
यह फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग का जो भी डे वन से
लेकर डे 100 डे 11 जितने भी क्लासेस
रहेंगी उसमें जितने भी पीपीटी यूज होने
वाली हैं वह सारी की सारी आपको लाइफ टाइम
एक्सेस र में मिलेगा प्लस में आपको
सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा ओके तो किसी का और कोई
सवाल मुझसे पूछ सकता है और एक चीज है आज
की क्लास में आप लोगों से एक चीज
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं मेरी रिक्वेस्ट यह है
कि आपको क्या करना है कि आपको आज म साथ के
साथ परफॉर्म ना करें आज मैं आप मैं चाहता
हूं कि आप जितने से ज्यादा से ज्यादा
पार्टिसिपेट करोगे मैं आपको हर पॉइंट पर
हर छोटी से छोटी चीज के लिए मैं क्या
करूंगा आपसे क्वेश्चन पूछा कि मुझे अभी
क्या करना चाहिए आप आपको क्या करना है
सिंपली चैट बॉक्स ओपन रखिए देखते रहिए और
साथ में सेम टाइम जैसे ही मैं आपको कुछ भी
सवाल पूछता हूं सेम टाइम आप चैट में
रिप्लाई करें मैक्सिमम स्टूडेंट
पार्टिसिपेट करें अभी 40 है तो 50
स्टूडेंट हो भी आई होप कि 50 हां बिल्कुल
आज फुल प्रैक्टिकल है थरेट कल थोड़ा सा
रहेगा जहां पर एक्सप्लेन करना है तो 40 टू
50 स्टूडेंट हो जाएंगे तो 40 50 स्टूडेंट
में एटलीस्ट मैं मानता हूं कि 38 होल्ड ऑन
गाइस जस्ट गिव मी वन मिनट समवन ऑन माय डोर
जस्ट होल्ड ऑन
सेक ओके
तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना है आज की क्लास
में पूरा कंपलीटली मेरे को पार्टिसिपेट
करना है मेरे साथ मैं जो भी पूछता हूं
आपको मेरे को कोऑपरेट करना है प्लीज आई
रिक्वेस्ट आज प्रैक्टिकल ना करें और आप
प्रैक्टिकल कब करें जैसे क्लास एंड हो
जाएगी आज सफ टेक्निक्स टैक्टिक्स सीखें
बिल्कुल इजी सीटीएफ है बहुत ही आसान
सीटीएफ है हम आसान से स्टार्ट करेंगे और
थोड़ा एक लेवल तक जाएंगे हर रोज सीटीएफ का
थोड़ा-थोड़ा हम लेवल बढ़ाएंगे धीरे-धीरे
और उसके बाद एक पॉइंट पर जाके हम रुक
जाएंगे जहां पर आपको बहुत सारे ट्रिक्स और
टेक्निक्स देखने को मिलेंगी और मैं चाहता
हूं कि ज्यादा से ज्यादा आपको क्या करना
है पार्टिसिपेट करना चैट में मैं
एक्सपेक्ट करता हूं ज्यादा से ज्यादा आपको
मैं जो भी आपसे सवाल पूछता हूं उसका आंसर
मुझे मिलना चाहिए सो दैट आपको भी अवेयर
रहे कि आपको कितनी नॉलेज है मुझे भी पता
चल जाए कि आपको किस पॉइंट तक नॉलेज है
ताकि हम एक साथ का इस सीटीएफ को परफॉर्म
करेंगे और जैसे ही आप नेक्स्ट डे क्या
करोगे जैसे क्लास खत्म हो जाएगी आज की
क्लास के बाद भी कर सकते हो नेक्स डे कर
सकते हो तो इसका फि प्रैक्टिस कीजिए आप
वीडियो को देखिए या ब्लाइंड आपने मैंने जो
भी आपसे सवाल पूछा सवाल का आपने जवाब दिया
सही या गलत आपको पता चल जाएगा फिर उसके
बाद आप अपनी मर्जी से लैब को सॉल्व कीजिए
उसके फ्लैग को सबमिट कीजिए और आप लिंकडन
पर उसको टैग कर दीजिए डिफरेंस अकेडमी पर
मैं चाहता हूं कि मैक्सिम से मैक्सिम
स्टूडेंट यह करें तो हो जाएगा सभी मेरे
साथ कॉपरेट करोगे एवरीवन और स्टूडेंट्स आज
भी बहुत कम आए हैं दे ओनली 36 स्टूडेंट्स
यार
कोई नहीं आई विल नॉट कमेंट एनी एनी
वन आपका चैट पढ़ लिया है जय शहा तो कोई ना
कोई आपकी हेल्प कर देगा अभी
चैट ओके मैं चाहता हूं मैक्सिमम लोग
पार्टिसिपेट करें आज की क्लास में बहुत
इजी लैंग्वेज है मुझे पता कि जिसको पहले
से पता होगी तो प्लीज वो सीटीएफ का आंसर
देने की कोशिश ना करें बाकी लोगों को
जिसको नहीं आता टीएफ सोल्स करने वो कर
लेंगे उनको सीख जाएंगे ओके तो हम स्टार्ट
करें सबसे पहले एवरीवन विद
मी आर यू रेडी
गाइस अभी मुझे सबसे चाहिए आंसर दे 41
स्टूडेंट्स मुझे सभी से आंसर चाहिए दे
टोटल 41 स्टें ल आर यू रेडी गाइस
ओके वेरी गुड लेट्स गो तो फिर हम एक काम
करते हैं चलते हैं स्क्रीन पर और फिर से
पैरेलल चीजें हम परफॉर्म करेंगे ओके तो
सबसे पहले मैं आपको सिखाता हूं कि अगर
आपको कोई भी सीटीएफ सॉल्व करना है ट्राई
हैक म के ऊपर तो आपको ट्राई हैक म के लैब
एक्सेस की जरूरत मतलब आपको ट्राई हैक म की
मशीन यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं है आप उस
सीटीएफ को ओपन वीपीएन के थ्रू अपनी मशीन
में कनेक्ट करके उस सीटीएफ को सॉल्व कर
सकते हो ओके तो कैसे कर सकते हैं मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं यह मेरा काली
तो हम सिंपली क्या ट्राई हैक मी पर जाते
हैं तो आज की जो मेरी लैब रहेगी वो पिकल
रिक रहेगी मैं आपको बता दूंगा कैसे यूज
करेंगे हम फिर भी डैशबोर्ड पर चलते हैं
इसको मैं थोड़ा जूम कर देता
हूं यस दिस इज द जूम यस तो आपको सिंपली
क्या करना है गो टू योर प्रोफाइल और यहां
पर एक्सेस पर जाना है गो टू एक्सेस टैब और
आपको सिंपली यहां पर क्या करना है यहां पर
देखो मशीनस है सर्वर्स है आप चाहे तो कोई
भी सिलेक्शन ले सकते हो जो आपकी मर्जी के
हिसाब से सिंपली मेरा है ऑलरेडी और सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है री जनरेट करना है और इस
फाइल को डाउनलोड कर लेना है डाउनलोड
कॉन्फिन फाइल जब यह फाइल एक बार आपकी
डाउनलोड हो जाएगी आपको सिंपली गो टू योर
डाउनलोड टैब आपको सिंपली डाउनलोड के अंदर
जाना है और देखना कि फाइल कहां पर है अभी
देखो मेरा डाउनलोड टैब में दिया लट ऑफ
फाइल्स बट जैसे आपकी प्रोफाइल है प्रोफाइल
नेम के बाद ओवीपीएन आ जाएगा ये ओपन वीपीएन
की एक फाइल रहेगी तो ये ऐसे करना है देन
आपको सिंपली गो टू यर टर्मिनल कैसे जाओगे
य रहा टर्मिनल प हम जाते हैं अ मैं
टर्मिनल जूम कर
दूंगा ये
रहा यह रहा अभी मैं इसको थोड़ा जूम कर
देता
हूं यह रहा और सिंपली आपको क्या करना है
गो टू योर डाउनलोड डायरेक्टरी तो हम क्या
करते हैं अभी
एलस ओके सीडी
डाउनलोड्स उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है
सबसे पहले आपको आपकी मशीन में ओपन वीपीएन
का पैकेज डाउनलोड होना चाहिए नॉर्मली ओपन
वीपीएन का पैकेज बाय डिफॉल्ट मशीन में आता
है अगर नहीं भी आता तो एटी डाउनलोड ओपन
वीपीएन करके आप डाउनलोड कर सकते हो शायद
यह बेसिक सबको आता होगा तो मैं सिंपली
क्या करूंगा अभी एलस करता हूं तो मेरे पास
क्या है f ओवीपीएन यह कॉन्फिन फाइल है
हमारी ट्राई हैमी की जिसके थ्रू मैं क्या
मशीन को कनेक्ट कर सकता हूं अभी मैं क्या
करने वाला हूं अभी इफ कॉन्फिन फिग अभी ये
मेरे पास टीए 0 और ए लोकल होस्ट मेरे पास
दो ही मशी दो ही इथरनेट शो कर रहा है एक
तो लोकल होस्ट दूसरा मेरा टीए 0 ये मेरा
आईपी एड्रेस है अभी मैं क्या करूंगा
सिंपली मुझे क्या करना है सुडो उसके बाद
ओपन वीपीए आपको देन उसके बाद कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल नेम जैसे मैं मैं f ओवीपीएन ओवीपीएन
और सिंपली आपको क्या करना है हिट एंटर
जैसे एंटर करोगे आपको अपना अ रूट पासवर्ड
ऐड ऑन करना है और यह रहा मैं ओपन वीपीएन
सर्वर के साथ क्या हो जाऊंगा कनेक्ट हो
जाऊंगा ट्राई हैक नहीं के अब मैं कैसे चेक
कर सकता हूं वो चेक करने के लिए गो ट योर
फाइल टैब न्यू टैब आपको सिंपली क्या करना
फिर से इसको मैं जूम करता हूं यह रहा देन
इफ कन्फ इफ कॉन्फिन चेक करता हूं तो यह
देखिए ट जीरो मतलब मैं अभी जो मेरा ओपन
वीपीएन है उसके थ्रू मैं क्या कर गया
ट्राई हैक म के सर्वर के साथ कनेक्ट कर
लिया अभी यहां पर भी चेक कर सकते हैं आजकल
लेटेस्ट ट्राई हैक में के अंदर जैसे मैं
इसको रिफ्रेश करूंगा कनेक्शन मेरा एब्लिश
हो गया यू आर रेडी स्टार्ट हैकिंग ओके तो
यह सब सबका हो जाएगा एवरीवन सब लोग कर
लोगे
यह मैंने आपको बता दिया ना अभी अखिलेश राव
रंजन मैंने आपको बताया कि कैसे करना है आप
इस आपको प्रोफ ये रहा क्लिक करना है
एक्सेस में जाओगे तो इस तरीके से डैशबोर्ड
दिख रहा है डैशबोर्ड में आपको कॉन्फिन
फाइल को डाउनलोड करना है देन डाउनलोड
डायरेक्टरी में जाना है सुडो ओपन वीपीएन
और उस फाइल को क्या करना है सीधा रन कर
देना है तो आप डायरेक्टली क्या करोगे
ट्राई हैक में के सर्वर के साथ कनेक्ट हो
जाओगे सब लोग का हो जाएगा सब कुछ क्लियर
है यहां तक एवरीवन
बताइए सभी का आंसर चाहिए
मुझे एवरीवन
क्लियर ओके वेरी गुड तो अभी हम क्या करने
वाले
हैं नहीं इंद्रजीत क्या होता कि जो आपका
काली लिनक्स मशीन है उसमें बाय डिफॉल्ट
ओपन वीपीएन आता है अगर आपकी मशीन में ओपन
वीपीएन डाउनलोड नहीं है तो आप सिंपली क्या
कर सकते हो डायरेक्टली आपको क्या करना है
गो टू र टर्मिनल टैब क्या करोगे सुडो एटी
इंस्टॉल इंस्टॉल ओपन वीपीएन ओपन वीपीएन आप
क्या कर सकते हो इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो तो
आपकी ओपन वीपीएन की जो फाइल है डाउनलोड हो
जाएगी आपके काली नेक्स के अंदर लेकिन बाय
डिफॉल्ट यह ओपन वीपीएन आपके मशीन के अंदर
आता है अभी लेट्स स्टार्ट आवर फर्स्ट
सीटीएफ फर्स्ट लैब तो मुझे सिंपली गो टू
माय
डैशबोर्ड गो टू माय लर्निंग पाथ सर्च और
जो लैब का नाम है वह है मेरा पिकल रिक पी
आई सी के एल ई पिकल रिक ओके यह हो गया हो
गया हो
गया अरे यार
यह रहा तो मुझे क्या करना
है क्लिक करना दिस इज आवर सीटीएफ लैब
ओके फिकल
रिक अभी आपको क्या करना जवाइन करना है और
अभी यह मेरी एक सीटीएफ लैब है अभी सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है इस लैब के अंदर आना है
पिकल रिक के अंदर और सिंपली आपको स्टार्ट
मशीन करना है जैसे आप मशीन को स्टार्ट
करोगे इस अगेंस्ट आपको एक आईपी एड्रेस
एलोकेट हो जाएगा नेक्स्ट 0 मिनट के अंदर
अभी मेरे पास प्रीमियम है प्रीमियम के
अंदर क्या है कि आप यूज आपको दो घंटे के
लिए लैब एक्सेस मिलता है आप चाहो तो उसको
ऐड वन ववर कर सकते लेकिन फ्री में शायद वन
वर्स के लिए मिलता है तो आप फ्री में भी
उसको यूज कर सकते हो तो प्रीमियम वाले के
लिए बेनिफिट है लेकिन फ्री के लिए थोड़ी
सी डिसएडवांटेज है कि यह लैब एक्सेस ओनली
वन ववर के लिए मिलता है और शायद में भी ऐड
कर सकते हो आप ऐड कर सकते हो मैंने अभी
फ्री यूज नहीं किया है तो मेरे पास
प्रीमियम है तो नो
इशू में की जितनी भी लैब आप सॉल्व कर सकते
हो सबके लिए ओपन वीपीएन का कन्फ फाइल को
यूज करके आप सॉल्व कर सकते
हो ओके अच्छी बात है सुरजो सिंह आपने बता
दिया ओके तो अभी आईपी एड हमें एक बार मिल
जाए ओके यह रहा दिस इज आवर आईपी एड्रेस हम
इसको सिंपली कॉपी करते हैं एंड गो टू
आवर टर्मिनल सबको टर्मिनल दिखाई दे रहा है
एवरीवन थोड़ा सा और जूम करना है तो बताइए
मुझे थोड़ा सा और जूम करने की आवश्यकता है
मुझे
यस सेम रहेगी आपकी य कॉन्फिन फाइल बारबार
आपको जरूरत नहीं है ओके तो अभी मेरे पास
एक आईपी एड्रेस है मेरे पास एक आईपी
एड्रेस है कौन सा कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व किया 10
डट 10.9 6108 मेरे पास एक आईपी एड्रेस है
अभी सबसे पहली चीज मैं क्या करूंगा सबसे
पहली चीज अगर मेरे पास एक आईपी एड्रेस है
तो हम सबसे पहली चीज क्या
करेंगे सबसे पहली चीज हम क्या करेंगे
बताओ सबसे पहली चीज हम क्या करेंगे जब भी
आपको कोई भी आईपी एड्रेस मिलेगा सबसे पहली
चीज आप क्या
करोगे नहीं वॉल्यूम सही है यार ओके
ओके ओके बताइए बताइए
बताइए ओके स्कैन करेंगे पिंग करेंगे स्कैन
करेंगे एन मैप करेंगे पट स्कैन करेंगे और
कोई किसी का और कोई जवाब एन मैप करेंगे
किसी का और किसी का और कोई
जवाब और
कुछ आईपी कन्फी क्यों
करेंगे ओके जिनका जवाब पिंग है वो सही है
सबसे पहले हम पिंग करेंगे सबसे पहला काम
होता है हमारा पिंग करना क्यों क्योंकि
हमें यह पता लगाना है कि जो मेरा टारगेट
आईपी एड्रेस है क्या वह एक्टिव है या नहीं
है सबसे पहला काम हमारा यही है कि जो मेरा
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस है वो एक्टिव भी है या
नहीं है ओके सबसे पहला काम जिसने पिंग
बोला वो राइट था तो सबसे पहले हम क्या
करेंगे पिंग उसके बाद कंट्रोल शिफ्ट v और
हिट एंटर हमने इसको एंटर कर दिया अभी मेरी
मशीन पिंग कर रही है और हम जो पैकेट उसको
भेज रहे हैं उसका रिप्लाई मिल रहा है इसका
मतलब जो मेरा टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस है वह
क्या है एक्टिव है ओके वह क्या है एक्टिव
है अभी मैं कंट्रोल सी करता हूं स्टॉप कर
दिया मुझे एक चीज बताइए मेरा एक सवाल है
कि ये आपका पिंग रिजल्ट है मैं आपको और भी
जूम कर देता हूं यह रहा ये रहा यह आपका
पिंग रिजल्ट आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
क्या इस रिजल्ट को देख
के कुछ मशीन के बारे में कोई और
इंफॉर्मेशन आप प्रोवाइड कर सकते
हो कोई और इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड कर सकते
हैं बताइए यह मेरा पिंग रिजल्ट है यह मेरा
आउटपुट है कि 15 पैकेट हमने भेजे एक भी
पैकेट लॉस नहीं हुआ इसका मतलब एक्टिव है
इस आउटपुट को देख के क्या मैं मशीन के
बारे में कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन बता सकता हूं कोई
भी इंफॉर्मेशन किसी को लगता है
बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए मुझे सबसे आंसर
चाहिए मैक्सिमम स्टूडेंट पार्टिसिपेट करने
चाहिए क्लास के अंदर मैक्सिमम
स्टूडेंट और
कोई और कोई बताइए और कोई बताइए जल्दी
जल्दी जल्दी
हैं गोल सिम
बफर यस जिन्होंने ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेल्स
बोला कौन से टाइप का ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वो
सही है व्हिच टाइप ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम व्हिच टाइप ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
बताइए व्हिच टाइप ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
बताइए बताइए
बताइए सभी को पार्टिसिपेट करना है किसी को
भी अगर किसी कोई आंसर गलत भी दे रहा है तो
मुझे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है बट मुझे आंसर
चाहिए च टाइप ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ओके
लिनक्स विंडोज 64 बिट क्या कह रहे हो यार
64 बिट लिनक्स जी एनय लिनक्स 64 बिट का
मतलब क्या है
भाई विच टाइप ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम दिस इज ए लिनेक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
ओके कैसे पता चला आप लोगों को लिनेक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है अगला सवाल पूरी क्लास
में ऐसे सवाल जवाब रहेंगे आप लोगों को मजा
आएगा आप लोगों कैसे पता चला कि कौन से
टाइप का ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है
यह कैसे पता चला नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं कैसे
पता पाए आपकी च टाइप ऑफ रेडििंग सिस्टम कि
मुझे इस प इस पिंग रिजल्ट के अंदर मैंने
एक ऐसी चीज देखी कि इसके आधार पर मैं
आईडिया लगा सकता हूं कि यह इस टाइप का
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होगा
बताइए नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं बताइए
बताइए बताइए
एवरीवन नहीं शुभम
रंग और
कोई बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए जल्दी से गलत
चलेगा बट पार्टिसिपेट करना
है नहीं अगर विंडोज पर फायर वल एक्टिवेट
नहीं होगा
तो यस वेरी गुड जिसने बोला टीटीएल टीटीएल
वैल्यू से आप आईडिया लगा सकते हो कि यह
कौन से टाइप की मशीन होगी टीटीएल क्या
होता है टाइम टू लीव किसी को पता है
टीटीएल वैल्यू क्या होती है या जिसने
टीटीएल वैल्यू बोला टीटीएल वैल्यू इ राइट
क्योंकि हर एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हर एक
सर्वर की एक टीटीएल वैल्यू होती है किसी
भी एक पैकेट की एक लाइफ होती है ओके तो
उसके बेस पर आप आईडिया लगा सकते हो कि यह
विंडोज मशीन है या लिनक्स मशीन है ओके
टीटीएल वैल्यूज की एक लिस्ट होती है अगर
मैं आपको शो करता हूं यह रहा गो टू आवर
न्यू टैब
एंड टीटीएल वैल्यू वैल्यूज
टेबल
रही ओके यह
रहा एक ये पिक्चर है मेरे
सामने फिर भी नॉट राइट गैस
तो एक एक अच्छी सी मेरे पास एक थी एक
आर्टिकल था जहां पर सभी टीटीएल वैल्यू के
बारे में थोड़ा सा जिक्र किया हुआ था
चलो इससे एक आईडिया ले सकते हो यह रही एक
लिस्ट है आप इसको आईडिया ले सकते हो कि
ओके कि 60 होगी 30 होगी नॉर्मली क्या है
कि अगर 120 से 128 आपको वैल्यू देखने को
मिलती है टीटीएल वैल्यू तो विंडोज मशीन के
चांसेस होते हैं अगर 60 टू 64 के बीच में
देखने को मिलती है तो
255 यह देखिए मैक ओ के लिए 60 64 अ 62 63
के बीच में आपकी क्या है नक् मशीन हो सकती
है 120 से 128 के बीच में आपकी विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो सकता है देखिए यहां पर
जो टीटीएल वैल्यू देख तो ये एक टेबल है आप
इसको एक रेफरेंस के लिए ले सकते हो मैं
आपके लिए इसको मैं चैट में भेज देता हूं
एक
बार यह रहा
ओके तो आपको आईडिया हो गया टीटीएल वैल्यू
के थ्रू तो चलो इससे हमें आईडिया लगाया कि
हमने गेस किया गैस वर्क किया कि ओके
टीटीएल वैल्यू के आधार पर मैंने यह पता
लगाया कि एक लिनक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो
सकता है ओके तो बट वी आर नॉट श्यर हम शोर
नहीं कि ये लिनेक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है या
नहीं है क्यों क्योंकि टीटीएल वैल्यू को
चेंज भी किया जा सकता
अगर एडमिन चाहे तो टीटीएल वैल्यू को चेंज
भी कर सकता है मैनुअली तो इसके बेस पर
हमने जस्ट गेस वर्क किया क्योंकि ये
लिनक्स मशीन हो सकती है लेकिन वी आर नॉट
शोर तो उसके लिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा
उसके लिए हमें जो दूसरी इंफॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल है इस टारगेट के ऊपर उसको क्रॉस
चेक करना होगा और उसके बेस पर हमें क्या
करना होगा यह फाइंड आउट करना होगा कि चच
टाइप ऑफ दिस मशीन ओके किस टाइप के मशीन है
अभी मेरे पास एक आईपी एड्रेस है हमें यह
पता है कि यह एक नक्स मशीन है जिसका हमें
आईडिया लगाया हमने तो अभी मुझे इस आईपी
एड्रेस को हैक करना है तो कैसे हैक करूंगा
क्या करूंगा हैक करने के लिए मुझे ओके
क्या करने क्या करूंगा क्या डायरेक्टली इस
आईपी एड्रेस को मैं हैक कर सकता हूं
डायरेक्टली अगर हां तो अगर मैं डायरेक्टली
आईपी एड्रेस को हैक कर सकता हूं तो क्या
हैक करूंगा मेरा सवाल ये कि मेरे पास आईपी
एड्रेस है आईपी एड्रेस मेरा एक्टिव है और
मुझे इस आईपी एड्रेस को हैक करना है तो हम
कैसे करेंगे क्या डायरेक्टली इस आईपी
एड्रेस को मैं हैक कर सकता हूं अगर
डायरेक्टली इस आईपी एड्रेस को मैं हैक कर
सकता हूं तो क्या हैक करूंगा आईपी एड्रेस
में मैं बताइए क्या हैक करूंगा मैं आईपी
एड्रेस में बताइए बताइए बताइए
बताइए डायरेक्टली कर सकता
हूं बिल्कुल वेरी गुड हमें सबसे पहले क्या
करना होगा पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करना होगा हमें
क्या करना होगा सबसे पहले पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
करना होगा और पोर्ट स्कैनिंग के आधार पर
हमें यह पता लगाना होगा कि कौन-कौन सी
सर्विसेस रन कर रही है इस आईपी एड्रेस के
ऊपर तो उसके लिए हम क्या करेंगे एन मैप
टूल का यूज करेंगे तो मैं एक बार सुडो
करता हूं एस यू स्विच यूज करता हूं मुझे
एक चीज बताइए मुझे अगर ए मैप का यूज
करेंगे हम अगर मुझे ए मैप में डिफॉल्ट
स्कैन करना है तो कैसे करूंगा मैं
अगर मुझे एन मैप में डिफॉल्ट स्कैन करना
तो कैसे
करूंगा एंड मैप के अंदर मुझे डिफॉल्ट
स्कैन करना तो मैं कैसे करूंगा या वेरी
गुड वेरी गुड यही मैं चाहता था तो हम क्या
करेंगे अभी कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व डिफॉल्ट स्कैन
परफॉर्म करेंगे ओके इट्स माय मिस्टेक तो
हमें आईपी एड्रेस उठाना होगा हमारा मशीन
का क्या था अभी फिर
से कॉपी एंड दिस वन ना
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व य और सिंपली हिट एंटर तो
यह अभी डिफॉल्ट स्कैन करेगा मुझे एक चीज
बताइए मेरा एक सवाल आप लोगों से कि जब भी
मैं एन मैप के अंदर बहुत सारे फीचर्स होते
हैं और एन मैप अपने टास्क परफॉर्म करने के
लिए कुछ प्रिंसिपल का फॉलो करता है तो उस
प्रिंसिपल का नाम क्या है व्ट टाइप ऑफ
प्रिंसिपल इट इ फॉलोइंग ड्यूरिंग
परफॉर्मिंग इट्स टास्क जब भी अपना टास्क
परफॉर्म करता है कोई भी तो व वि टाइप ऑफ
प्रिंसिप फॉलो कौन से टाइप का प्रिंसिपल
फॉलो करता है कोई बताएगा
मुझे बताइए मुझे बताइए जल्दी से जल्दी से
जल्दी से जल्दी से च टाइप ऑफ प्रिंसिपल वी
आर फॉलोइंग
नो नो नो नो प्रिंसिपल है प्रिंसिपल है एन
मैप टूल मैंने आपको जब कंपलीटली पढ़ाया था
तो वो पूरा का पूरा एन मैप टूल्स एक प्रिल
पर साइकिल पर काम करता है क्या है वह
बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए और वो कांसेप्ट
पढ़ा चुका हूं आप लोगों को याद
कीजिए यस वेरी गुड जिसने भी एनाई म वर्ल्ड
आपका जो असली नाम है इट फॉलो द प्रिंसिपल
ऑफ टीसीपी आईपी हैंड शेक कौन सा प्रिंसिपल
टीसीपी आईपी हैंड शेक ओके तो अभी ड्यूरिंग
डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट स्कैनिंग में हमने यह पता
लगाया कि कौन-कौन से पोर्टस ओपन पोर्ट 22
एसएसए एंड पोर्ट 80 व्हिच इज ओपन एचटीटीपी
हाइपर टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल ओके
मेरा एक और सवाल आप लोगों से कि क्या मैं
इस आईपी को डायरेक्टली जो एसएसए है आप
सबको पता है एसएस के थ्रू हम कैसे एंटर कर
सकते हैं मशीन के अंदर क्या मैं
डायरेक्टली इस आईपी को इस एसस के ऊपर यूज
कर सकता हूं कि या इस एसएसएस सर्विस के
थ्रू डायरेक्टली मैं लॉग इन कर सकता हूं
आईपी का यूज करके कर सकता हूं मैं बताइए
मुझे अगर हां तो कैसे और अगर नहीं तो
क्यों नहीं कर
सकता मुझे आंसर
चाहिए बताइए बताइए बताइए
बताइ यस कर सकते हैं तो कैसे कर सकते
हैं बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए जल्दी
से
नहीं नहीं मुझे मेरा सवाल यह है आप लोगों
से कि इस एसएसएस सर्विस का यूज करके अभी
इस कंडीशन में मैं क्या आईपी एड्रेस को
यूज करके मशीन के अंदर एंटर कर सकता हूं
या नहीं कर सकता अगर कर सकता हूं अगर आपका
जवाब यस है तो कैसे कर सकता हूं अगर आपका
जवाब नो है तो मैं क्यों नहीं कर
सकता बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए जल्दी से
नहीं नहीं नहीं शुभम सर्विस वल्नरेबल है
तो कर सकते कैसे कर सकते हैं नहीं नहीं
नहीं बताइए बताइए
बताइए जिनका नो है तो यस कुछ लोगों ने
इसका जवाब दिया है इसका उनका जवाब यही कि
नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि उसके लिए हमें यूजर
नेम और पासवर्ड चाहिए क्रेडेंशियल चाहिए
ओके क्रेडेंशियल चाहिए क्या अभी तक हमारे
पास कोई भी यूजर्स नेम एंड पासवर्ड है अभी
तक क्या हमारे पास में कोई भी यूजर नेम और
पासवर्ड है कोई भी यूजरनेम पासवर्ड है अभी
तक नो क्योंकि अभी तक हमने क्या है कि
जितनी भी इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आट की जस्ट
हमने पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग को स्टार्ट किया
है एक आईपी के ऊपर जस्ट पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग को स्टार्ट किया है तो अभी तक
हमारे पास कोई भी यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड की
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है तो ओके ए सर्विस के
बारे में पता तो नेक्स्ट जो सर्विस है
टीटीपी पोर्ट नंबर 80 जो ओपन है इसका क्या
करें इसके बारे में क्या है हाइपर टैक्स
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल इसके बारे में
क्या इसके बारे में
क्या देखिए एक चीज ध्यान
रखना दोनों केस में किसी भी सर्विस के केस
में देखो जो एचटीटीपी टीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल है
हाइपर टैक्स ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल है क्या
यह किसी
भी सर्वर के ऊपर क्या हो सकता है सिचुएटेड
हो सकता है हो सकता है व किसी भी चाहे वो
के ऊपर होस्ट हो सकता है इंप्लीमेंटेशन
अलग हो सकता है कि विंडोज के लिए ओपन
एसएसएस हो नक् के लिए आपका डायरेक्टली
एसएस कमांड के थ्रू हो इंप्लीमेंटेशन अलग
हो सकता है लेकिन होस्टेड किसी भी सर्विस
किसी के ऊपर भी हो सकता है चाहे वो विंडोज
हो
[संगीत]
के ऊपर होस्टेड है वो इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे
फाइंड आउट करूंगा मैं बताइए वो इंफॉर्मेशन
कैसे फाइंड आउट
करूंगा अगर मुझे यह पता लगाना है
कि एसएसए कौन सा इंप्लीमेंटेशन यूज कर रहा
है और
एचटीटीपी अपाची यूज कर रहा या एजक्स यूज
कर रहा है या कौन सा सर्वर यूज कर रहा है
यह कैसे पता लगाऊंगा बताइए सभी सभी आंसर
मी आंसर
मी प्लीज एज फास्ट एस पॉसिबल यस हम उसके
लिए करेंगे सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन करेंगे
तो कैसे करेंगे एन मैप हाइन सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन देन उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
लो और हिट एंटर
नाउ यह
रहा
ओके इट विल टेक
टाइम यस अभी हमें पता चल गया जो एसएसए है
वो यूज कर रहा है ओपन
ओपन एसएसएस 8.2 p1 और पोर्ट ए आपका यूज कर
रहा है अचे एचटीटीपीडी
2.4.41 ऊपर से नटू की मशीन है तो अभी
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन से हमें पता चल गया
कि जो ये मेरी मशीन है यह नक्स मशीन है
क्योंकि पिं के थ्रू हमने क्या किया जस्ट
गेस किया था कि हमने आईडिया लगाया था ओके
ये एक
[संगीत]
कौन सी
एड्रेस 101.9 मेरा 108 ही है क्या मे बी
ओके यस 9618 है मेरा आईपी एड्रेस और
सिंपली मैं क्या करता हूं अभी हिट एंटर कर
देता हूं यह
रहा यह रहा यह मेरा हिट एंटर किया मैंने
जूम कर देता हूं अभी यह क्या आपकी एक
वेबसाइट है और वेबसाइट का ये एक वेब पेज
है तो अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं वेबसाइट
पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे हैं बेसिकली हम क्या
कर रहे हैं वेबसाइट पेन टेस्टिंग और जब एक
चीज का हमेशा ध्यान जब भी आप वेबसाइट पन
टेस्टिंग करेंगे तो आपको वेबसाइट के अंदर
हर एक छोटी से छोटी चीज हर एक छोटी से
छोटी चेंज हर एक लिंक उसके अंदर क्या-क्या
इमेजेस है कौन सा टैब्स है कौन सा लिंक्स
है क्या टेक्स्ट लिखा है और क्लिक करने पर
वेबसाइट के अंदर क्या चेंजेज हो रहे हैं
हर एक छोटी सी छोटी चीज को आपको क्या करना
है बहुत ही केयरफुली हैंडल करना है बहुत
बहुत ही सावधानी से आपको नोटिस करना है
मतलब आपने कहीं पर क्लिक किया उसकी वजह से
यूआरएल में में कुछ चेंज हुआ या आपके
टेक्स्ट में कुछ चेंज हुआ या इमेज में कुछ
चेंज हुआ कहां पर क्लिक करने से क्या
इफेक्ट हुआ है कौन-कौन से पोटेंशियल अटैक
वेक्टर्स हैं एंट्री पॉइंट है वेबसाइट के
अंदर वो सारी की सारी चीजें आपको क्या
करना है हमेशा ड्यूरिंग वेबसाइट पेन
टेस्टिंग ये सारे पॉइंट आपको ध्यान में
रखना है अभी हमारे केस में क्या है हमारे
पास एक तो ये क्या है कुछ टेक्स्ट लिखा
हुआ है और एक हमारे पास इमेज है ठीक है एक
इमेज और एक आपको टेक्स्ट देखने को मिल रहा
है ऊपर क्या है यूआरएल में कुछ नहीं 10.10
96.1 है अभी यहां पर एक इमेज आपको देखने
को मिल रहा है अभी इमेज के केस में हो
सकता है कि इस इमेज के अंदर कोई
इंफॉर्मेशन हिडन हो हो सकता है कोई मशियल
कोड हिडन हो या कोई मशियल कमांड हिडन हो
या कुछ ऐसी इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन हाइड की
गई हो इस इमेज के अंदर जो हमारे लिए फर्द
अटैक के लिए काफी वैल्युएबल हो और जब भी
हम बात करते हैं चाहे वो ऑडियो के ऑडियो
हो वीडियो हो चाहे आपका इमेज हो इमेज के
अंदर कोई भी अगर मुझे कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन
हाड हाइड करनी है उस केस में कांसेप्ट आता
है जिसका नाम स्टेगी जिसका नाम क्या होता
है स्टेगी डज एनी वन नो अबाउट
स्टेगी किसी को पता है कोई अवेयर है कि
स्टग ग्राफी होती क्या है
बताइए स्टेगी क्या होता है बताइए एनी वन
नोज किसी को भी आईडिया है कि स्टेग्रिड
ग्राफी पूछ रहा हूं स्टेग्रिड
समथिंग इन पीडीएफ फोटोज एटस ओके हाइडिंट
इनसाइड इमेजेस ऑडियो फाइल्स टेक्स्ट
फाइल्स पीडीएफ फाइल्स या वीडियो फाइल्स
मतलब किसी भी इमेज किसी भी ऑडियो किसी भी
पीडीएफ फाइल के अंदर किसी भी मलेशियन
मिशिस कमांड को हाइड करना आपका कहलाता है
स्टेग्रिड
ग्राफी मुझे एक टर्म और होती है स्टग
एनालिसिस वह क्या होता है
फिर स्टग एनालिसिस क्या होता है
अगर मैंने जब आपसे पूछा टेगो ग्राफी
हाइडिंट इनसाइड इमेजेस ऑडियो फाइल्स
वीडियो फाइल्स तो देन एक टर्म और होती है
स्टैग एनालिसिस वह क्या होती
है नहीं स्टैग एनालिसिस होते क्या है आई
वांट टू नो जस्ट आई वांट टू नो कि व्ट इज
स्टग
एनालिसिस व्ट इज स्टैग एनालिसिस
किसी को पता
है एनी वन नोज अबाउट इट व्हाट इज टैग
एनालिसिस यस शुभम राइट आंसर कि आपने
स्टेग्रिड
कर दिया अब उस इंफॉर्मेशन को मुझे
एक्सक्ला करना है पता करना है तो उस
टेक्निक को या उस प्रोसेस को हम बोलते हैं
गग एनालिसिस ओके तो आज की क्लास में मैं
आपको स्टेग्रिड
एनालिसिस आपको नहीं सिखाने वाला लेकिन हम
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में कुछ स्लैब्स में ओनली
स्टेग्रिड
ग्राफी के थ्रू आपने इंफॉर्मेशन को हाइड
किया और स्टैग एनालिसिस के थ्रू आपने उस
इंफॉर्मेशन को
एक्स्टेक्स्ट टेक्स्ट फाइल से उन पीडीएफ
फाइल से या उन वीडियोस या पीडीएफ इमेजेस
फाइल से तो उसको हम बोलते हैं स्टैग
एनालिसिस अभी के लिए हम क्या करेंगे इन
सारी की सारी इमेजेस को क्या करेंगे सेव
करेंगे फर्द स्टैग एनालिसिस के लिए तो
सिंपली राइट क्लिक ओपन इन न्यू टैब देन गो
टू माय न्यू टैब एंड इसको मैं क्या करता
हूं सेव करता हूं आपको हर एक इमेज को सेव
करना मैंने इसको सेव किया है सिंपली यह
रहा सेव इमेज एज ये रहा अभी इमेज वन इमेज
टू मैंने सेव किया हुआ है तो आप एज पर योर
रिक्वायरमेंट ओके मैंने सेव किया जितनी भी
इमेजेस फाइल आपको मिलेगी आपको क्या करना
सेव करना एक चीज मुझे बताइए जब भी मैंने
इस इमेज को यह रहा इमेज यहां पर थी और
जैसे मैं राइट क्लिक किया ओपन न्यू टैब न
टैब में ओपन किया मैंने यहां पर कुछ चेंज
आपको देखने को मिला यहां पर कुछ भी चेंज
यहां पर आपको देखने को
मिला कुछ भी चेंज आपको देखने को मिला कि
जब मैंने इस इमेज को नए टैब में ओपन किया
आपको यहां पर कुछ नोटिस कुछ नोटिस किया
आपने कुछ भी नोटिस किया हो
आज चेक करते हैं कि आप कितने फोकस के साथ
आज क्लास को पढ़ रहे हो बताइए कुछ भी आपने
नोटिस किया एनीथिंग एल्स कुछ भी
आपने नहीं यार फुल फोटो नहीं बताओ बताओ
बताओ
बताओ कुछ लोग यूआरएल बोल रहे हैं बाकी और
बाकी और किसी कोई गेस मेंट कोई भी गेस
कीजिए बताइए
बताइए द ड
जी ये रहा देखो कुछ भी आपने नोटिस
किया यस आपने अगर देखा होगा ध्यान से यह
था मेरी वेबसाइट
101.9
6108 जैसे ही न्यू टैब में मैंने ओपन किया
यह क्या मेरा
101.9 6.08 असेट्स उसके बाद इमेज नेम जपी
जीी यूआरएल में आपने कुछ देखा होगा यूआरएल
में यस गुड यहां पर एक डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
प्रॉब्लम इसको मैं जूम नहीं कर सकता एक
मिनट आई विल ट्राई कि स्ट्रेच हो जाए यस
अभी दिखाई दे रहा
है इसका मतलब होता है जैसे आपका ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है चाहे आपका लिनक्स ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है चाहे आपका विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम उसमें कैसे होता है फोल्डर फोल्डर
के अंदर सब फोल्डर उसके अंदर फाइल्स होती
है आपकी इमेजेस हो सकती है आपकी पीडीएफ
फाइल्स हो है हो सकती है आपके एमपी3
फाइल्स हो सकती है वीडियो फाइल्स हो सकती
है एमपी4 फाइल्स उसी तरीके से आपका विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर डायरेक्टरीज होती
हैं डायरेक्टरी के अंदर सब डायरेक्टरीज भी
हो सकती हैं या फाइल्स हो सकती है जैसे
कोई एग्जीक्यूटिव फाइल्स हो सकती है कोई
प्रोग्राम फाइल्स हो सकती है कोई टेक्स्ट
फाइल हो सकती है या कोई भी फाइल हो सकती
है उसी तरीके से वेबसाइट में भी होता है
वेबसाइट केस में कैसे हैंडल करते हैं
डायरेक्टरीज होती है डायरेक्टरीज के अंदर
सब डायरेक्टरीज भी हो सकती है एज पर द
वेबसाइट डिजाइन और उनके अंदर फाइल्स हो
सकती है या पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
फाइल्स हो सकती है जैसे सीएसएस फाइल हो
सकती है या आपके जा वावा स्क्रिप्ट फाइल
हो सकती है कोई पीएनजी फाइल हो सकती है
जेपीजी फाइल हो सकती है पीडीएफ फाइल हो
सकती है या कोई पीएचपी का कोड हो सकता है
तो इसी प्रकार से जैसे आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम में स्ट्रक्चर को हैंडल किया जाता
ऐसे वेबसाइट के केस में भी हैंडल किया
जाता डायरेक्टरी सब डायरेक्टरी और फाइल तो
ये वही चीज है अभी मैं क्या करूंगा अभी के
लिए हम क्या करते हैं सबसे पहले इस
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर चलते हैं और
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते
हैं कि इस डायरेक्टरी अंदर है क्या कि
10.10.10 हिट एंटर किया मैंने यहां पर
सिंपली ओके ये देखिए यहां पर मुझे क्या
मिला एक सीएसएस फाइल देखने को मिली एक
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल देखने को मिली यहां पर
फिर क्या देखो अभी सीएसएस फाइल में क्लिक
करता हूं मैं ये देखो क्लिक किया यहां पर
क्या देखने को मिल रहा है सीएसएस कोड है
किसी को पता है कि सीएसएस होता क्या
है व्हाट इज द यूज ऑफ सीएसएस एनी वन नोज
बताइए यस इट प्रोवाइड द स्टाइलिंग टू द
वेब पेजेस ओके तो क्या हमें इसको एनालाइज
करने की जरूरत
है क्या हमें इसको एनालाइज करना चाहिए इस
फाइल को बताइए
ओके तो गो बैक और अभी हमारे पास कौन सी है
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल इसको क्लिक करते हैं
हम यह हमारी जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल है यह
मेरी जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल
है क्या हमें जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल को
एनालाइज करना
चाहिए या जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल को एग्जामिन
करना हमारे लिए हेल्पफुल रहेगा या नहीं
रहेगा
बताइए यस सम टाइम्स हमारे हमारे लिए
हेल्पफुल हो सकता है हम क्या कर सकते हैं
कंप्लीट फाइल को एनालाइज नहीं करते हम
क्या करते हैं उसके अंदर कुछ पर्टिकुलर
इंफॉर्मेशन को फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं जैसे टोकेंस की इंफॉर्मेशन या
पासवर्ड्स की इंफॉर्मेशन या कुछ कीज की
इंफॉर्मेशन या कुछ और अदर पैरामीटर्स हम
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं जो हमार
जो क्या कर सकते हैं आपके लिए सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन को क्या कर सकते हैं प्रोवाइड
कर सकते हैं जो आपको सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड कर सकते हैं तो वो सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आप क्या कर सकते हो
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल के अंदर फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो तो अभी के लिए
मुझे एजामिन नहीं कर रहा इसको मैं अभी
यहां पर देखो जिप फाइल है जे मन जस है अभी
देखो पर्ल जेपीजी यह रहा पोर्टल जेपीजी यस
इसको भी हम क्या करते हैं सेव कर लेते हैं
फॉर
फर्द स्टैक एनालिसिस के लिए सेव इमेजेस
नाउ इसको भी हम क्या करते हैं सिंपली
पोर्ल ड जेपीजी को भी सेव कर लेते हैं
डाउनलोड डायरेक्टरी के अंदर नाउ गो बैक यस
ओ माय गॉड इट्स ओके असेट डायरेक्टरी को य
ओपन करेंगे
यह रहा उसके बाद रिक एडम और मोर्टी जेपीजी
यह हम ऑलरेडी क्या कर चुके हैं सेम फाइल
को देखो यह रही य सेम फाइल है इसको हमने
सेव कर लिया फदर एस के लिए ओके अभी सबको
हमने क्या कर लिया डाउनलोड कर लिया अभी एक
चीज होती है वेबसाइट के केस में कि
वेबसाइट के दो हिस्से होते हैं दो पार्ट्स
होते हैं किसी को पता है वेबसाइट
के दो पार्ट्स होते हैं
चलो मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं कौन से
दो पार्ट्स होते हैं
देखो यह
रहा यह एक वेबसाइट है वेबसाइट में एक फ
फ्रंट एंड साइड होती है एक बैक एंड साइड
होती है पता चल गया कि वेबसाइट के अंदर एक
होती है फ्रंट एंड के साथ क्या है यूजर
जैसे कि क्लाइंट्स है या हम ट्रैक करते
हैं हमेशा वेबसाइट के और बैक एंड में
हमेशा क्या होता है सर्वर होता है सर्वर
चाहे वो
[संगीत]
एचटीएमएल आपकी मार्कअप लैंग्वेज है
आपके उसको स्ट्रक्चर डिजाइन करती है आपके
वेब पेज की सीएसएस आपकी कैस्केडिंग
स्टाइलिंग लैंग्वेज है आपके वेब पेज को
कलर्स हैं उसको थोड़ा बोल्ड इटैलिक उसका
किस टाइप का कलर देना है उसको डिजाइनिंग
प्रोवाइड करती है जावास्क्रिप्ट एक एक
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज है जो नाउ एडेज
आपकी एक तो क्या है कि डायनेमिक लुक है जो
वेबसाइट को डायनेमिक डायनामि प्रोवाइड
करते हैं उसके काम आती है दूसरी बैक एंड
में किसी एक नोट जेएस के रिएक्ट जेएस जैसे
फ्रेमवर्क के रूप में इसका यूज किया जाता
है ओके अब जो बैक एंड साइड है बैक एंड
साइड में क्या है कौन सी एक तो डेटाबेस
होता है बैक एंड साइड में हमेशा एक तो
डेटाबेस के साथ डील किया जाता है सर्वर के
ऊपर दूसरा साथ के साथ बैक एंड
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज होती है जैसे
पीएचपी होगी पाइथन होगी नट जेएस है आपका
जावास्क्रिप्ट का फ्रेमवर्क हो गया पर्ल
हो गी या सम टाइम सी लैंग्वेज होगी ये
सारी की सारी क्या आपकी बैक एंड
लैंग्वेजेस है तो ये आपको पता होना चाए जब
भी आप वेबसाइट के साथ डील कर रहे हो तो
वेबसाइट के दो फेस होते हैं एक तो फ्रंट
एंड फेस होता है आपका एक बैक एंड फेस होता
है फ्रंट एंड में हमेशा आपको
एटीएमएल गी जो यूजर इंटरेक्शन का पार्ट
होता है बैक एंड साइड में क्या है जो आपका
सर्वर के साथ कनेक्टेड होती है जहां पर
बैक एंड लैंग्वेज यूज की जाती है बैक एंड
लैंग्वेज में आपका पीएचपी होता है आपका
पाइथन होता है आपका नोड जेएस होता है
रिएक्ट जेएस हो गया एक्सप्रेस जेएस हो गया
या उसके बाद फिर डेटाबेस होता है आपका नो
एसक्यूएल माय एसक्यूएल तो इस टाइप से आपका
डेटाबेस होता होता है तो ये सारी चीज आपकी
डील होती है आपके बैक एंड साइड में तो
एवरीवन गट क्लियर कि वेबसाइट के दो फेस
होते हैं कोई आपसे पूछता है कि वेबसाइट के
जब भी आप वेबसाइट पन टेस्ट करोगे तो आप इन
सब चीजों से डील करते हो एवरीवन गट
क्लियर एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल नाउ सबको मजा
आ रहा है क्लास
में सब लोग एंजॉय कर रहे हो किसी को बोर
तो नहीं लग रहा कि किसी को लग रहा सर मैं
बहुत फील कर रहा हूं एनी
वन इंटरेस्टेड है
क्लास मेरे करवाने के बाद सीटी बहुत आसानी
से कर
लोगे ओके चलो हम चलते हैं फिर से अपनी
मशीन के ऊपर तो अभी हमें अभी हमने यह पता
कर लिया नाउ नेक्स्ट अब हम क्या करते हैं
एक बार टेक्स्ट को पढ़ते हैं एक बार हम
क्या करते हैं टेक्स्ट को भी पढ़ते हैं यह
रहा यह क्या था हमारा टेक्स्ट वाला पार्ट
है यह
रहा यह हमारा टेक्स्ट है अब टेक्स्ट को आप
सभी लोग एक बार स्क्रीन के ऊपर ध्यान से
पढ़िए और इससे एक आईडिया एक गेसिंग एक
पॉसिबिलिटी होती है ना वो क्रिएट करने की
कोशिश कीजिए कि यहां पर क्याक पॉसिबिलिटी
है आपके लिए क्या इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन
हो सकती है आपके लिए ओके
कौन-कौन सी इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन आपके
लिए यहां पर हो सकती है जैसे कि देखो
हेल्प मोर्टी लिसन मोर्टी आई नीड योर
हेल्प आई हैव टर्न माय सेल्फ इनटू ए पिकल
अगेन एंड दिस टाइम आई कांट चेंज बैक
नेक्स्ट आई नीड योर बर्ब मोटी लॉग ऑन टू
माय कंप्यूटर एंड फाइंड द लास्ट थ्री
सीक्रेट इंग्रेडिएंट्स टू फिनिश माय पिकल
रिवर्स पोशन अभी तीन सीक्रेट
इंग्रेडिएंट्स आपको फाइंड आउट करने हैं यह
हमें हिंट दे रहा है द ओनली प्रॉब्लम इज
आई हैव नो आईडिया व्ट द वर्ब पासवर्ड वाज
हेल्प मोर्टी हेल्प अभी यहां पर इसको पढ़
के अगर आपको कुछ आईडिया लगा पा रहे होगे
मुझे जो लग रहा है कि मोर्टी एक यूजर नेम
है मुझे जो मैं गेस कर पा रहा हूं मोर्टी
एक यूजर नेम है जो मुझे लग रहा है यह मेरा
क्या है पॉसिबिलिटी है मैंने यहां पर क्या
अपनी मर्जी से कुछ कुछ भी नहीं बनाया ना
मैं अपनी मर्जी से बता रहा हूं मुझे जो लग
रहा है इसके अंदर यह मोटी एक यूजर नेम है
यह मेरी पॉसिबिलिटी है संभावना है इसी
तरीके से आपकी भी पॉसिबिलिटी होनी चाहिए
उसके बाद वर्ब वर्ब आपने कहीं सुना होगा
ये जिक्र कर रहे हैं कि ओके वर्ब बब सूट
होता है हम आईडिया कर स बब का मतलब बब सूट
हो सकता है और यह बोल रहा है कि मेरे पास
बब सूट का पासवर्ड नहीं है कुछ ऐसा कुछ
जिक्र कर रहे हैं लेकिन हमें ये बोल रहे
हैं कि तीन सीक्रेट इंग्रेडिएंट्स को आप
क्या कीजिए इसमें फाइंड आउट कीजिए तो
हमारी लिए तो तीन सीक्रेट इंग्रेडिएंट्स
है तीन फ्लैग है जो हमें फाइंड आउट करने
हैं बट एक बात कर रहे हैं मोटी एक यूजर
नेम हो सकता है बर्ब ये शायद बर्ब शुट की
बात कर रहे होंगे एवरीवन गट क्लियर आई एम
नॉट
श्यर अभी आप लोगों का सवाल है सर आपने
मोटी यूजर नेम ही क्यों बोला होगा एज ए
ह्यूमन बीइंग चाहे मैं हूं आप है 99 पर जो
लोग होते हैं वह हमेशा अ अपना जो खुद का
नाम होता है उसी को ही मशीन का यूजर नेम
रखते हैं उसी को ही मशीन का यूजर नेम रखते
हैं आई एम राइट किसी को गलत तो नहीं लग
रहा
बताइए बताइए
बताइए क्योंकि आप में सभी एक ह्यूमन बीइंग
ही है हमेशा हम क्या करते हैं जो हमारा
नाम होता है उसी को हम क्या करते हैं अपना
यूजर नेम रखते तो यहां पर क्या मोर्टी की
बात हो रही थ एक यूजर नेम हो सकता है एक
और चीज नेक्स्ट चीज हम क्या करेंगे कि
हमेशा जब भी आप क्या करते हैं वेब पन
टेस्टिंग करते हैं तो हमें क्या करना होता
है हम हमें सोर्स कोड को देखना चाहिए
हमेशा वेबसाइट के सोर्स कोड को हमेशा हमें
देखना चाहिए कैसे देख सकते हैं राइट
क्लिक व्यू हमारा रहेगा व्यू पेज ये रहा
व्यू सिलेक्शन सोर्स नो नो नो सिलेक्शन
सोर्स नहीं चाहिए था हमें व्यू पेज सोर्स
चाहिए था हमें ओके व्यू पेज सोर्स राइट
क्लिक किया और इसको मैं जूम कर देता हूं
एक बार यह रहा आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा
अभी जब भी
हम पेज जो सोर्स कोड है उसको जब भी हम
देखने की बात करते हैं व्यू करने की बात
करते हैं तो इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि मैं
यह बोल रहा हूं कि यहां पर हमें
जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड देखने को मिलेगा या
सीएसएस कोड देखने को मिलेगा नहीं हमें
प्रेजेंट वेब पेज का जो कोड है किस तरीके
से उसको डिजाइन किया गया है बेसिकली उससे
हमें क्या है वेबसाइट के स्ट्रक्चर का
आईडिया होता है वेबसाइट के स्ट्रक्चर का
आईडिया होता है क्योंके उसके अंदर कौन सी
लैंग्वेज का यूज किया गया है सीएसएस
जावास्क्रिप्ट कौन-कौन सी फाइल का यूज कि
या कोई पीएचपी फाइल को यूज किया गया है वह
लिंक्स आपको मिलते हैं और मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट चीज आपको यहां पर जो मिल सकती
है वह आपको कमेंट अभी यहां पर देखिए
कमेंट्स यह रही नोट टू सेल्फ रिमेंबर यूजर
नेम यूजर नेम दिस इज द यूजर नेम यहां पर
आपको क्या मिला
आपको क्या मिला आपको यहां पर आपको यूजर
नेम मिल गया कमेंट्स अभी एक चीज बताइए
क्या कमेंट को यूज करना गलत है वेबसाइट के
अंदर
कोई बताएगा कि कमेंट्स को वेबसाइट के अंदर
यूज करना गलत
है नो क्योंकि जब भी आप किस फॉर एग्जांपल
आप एक डेवलपर हो और जब डेवलपिंग टीम में
आप एज ए टीम काम करते हो वहां पर आप कमेंट
का यूज करते हो और कमेंट को यूज करना गलत
नहीं है क्योंकि जब भी हम क्या करेंगे
वेबसाइट क्रिएट करते हैं कमेंट का यूज
करते हैं और जैसे नेक्स्ट हमारी टीम मेंबर
आता है उसका कमेंट को देख के आईडिया लगाते
कि ओके वेबसाइट में इतना काम हो गया है
अभी मुझे यहां से स्टार्ट करना है कमेंट
को यूज करना गलत नहीं है लेकिन जब वेबसाइट
एक बार रेडी हो जाती है जब वेबसाइट इज
रेडी टू गो टू लाइव जब उसे लाइव जाना होता
है जब उसको सर्वर पे होस्ट कर दिया जाता
है और जब वो यूजर फेस है जब वो लाइव जानी
होती है उस टाइम पर यह डेवलपर की या उस
टीम की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है उन सभी कमेंट
को उस वेबसाइट के अंदर से रिमूव करना ओके
ताकि कि उनकी वजह से कोई सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन बाहर ना चले हो सकता है उनके
पास जैसे कि यहां पर यूजर नेम है पासवर्ड
हो कुछ एपीआई कीज हो जो वेबसाइट को डेवलप
करने में हेल्प की होगी इंटरनल इंफॉर्मेशन
हो या कहीं पर आपने जब नेटवर्क जैसी
वेबसाइट को ज्यादा डील कर रहे तो वहां पर
कोई नेटवर्क इंफॉर्मेशन हो हो सकता है जो
बाहर के लिए इंपॉर्टेंट ना बाहर जो
क्लाइंट्स है उनके लिए ना बना हो लेकिन
इंटरनल टीम के लिए बनाया गया हो तो ये
सारी सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन आपको कमेंट के
थ्रू मिल सकती है इसलिए जो पेज सोर्स है
जो सोर्स कोड उसको व्यू करना वेरी वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट ओके तो अभी एक चीज हमने देखा
कि जब हमने जब भी क्लिक किया एक
डायरेक्टरी मिली डायरेक्टरी के अंदर कुछ
सेंसिटिव फाइल हमें मिली तो अभी हो सकता
है कि इस वेबसाइट के ऊपर और भी वेब पेजेस
हो या और भी डायरेक्टरीज हो और उनके अंदर
और भी क्या हो और भी फाइल्स हो अभी मुझे
उनके बारे में पता लगाना है तो उनके बारे
में मुझे फाइंड आउट करना तो कैसे फाइंड
आउट करूंगा एवरीवन
बताइए कैसे फाइंड आउट करूंगा उनके बारे
में मुझे अगर उनके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदर करनी है तो कैसे
करूंगा
बताइए नहीं बताइए अगर मुझे और भी ज्यादा
डायरेक्टरीज हैं या और भी फाइल्स है उनके
बारे में या और भी वेब पेजेस है उनके बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करनी हो तो मैं
कैसे फाइंड आउट करूंगा
बताइए कोई गेस कर सकता है एनी
आईडिया देर आर टू वेज एक तो मैनुअल
है दूसरा आपका क्या है ऑटोमेशन बोल सकते
हैं यूजिंग टूल्स यूजिंग टूल्स
ओके टूल का यूज करके कौन सा टूल डर बस्टर
या गो बस्टर जैसे टूल का यूज करके ओके तो
अभी मैनुअल जो हमने फाइंड आउट किया वह
काफी है एनफ है अपने टाइम को सेव करने के
लिए उसके बाद हमें क्या करना चाहिए
ऑटोमेशन पर शिफ्ट करना चाहिए बिफोर
ऑटोमेशन एक चीज है जो आप सबको पता होना
चाहिए एक फाइल होती है रोबोट एक्टी वो
जरूर हमें देखनी चाहिए क्योंकि एज ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर हमें उस फाइल को हमेशा
रीड करना चाहिए किसी भी वेबसाइट पेन
टेस्टिंग के दौरान व किसी भी पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर के लिए वेरी वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
फाइल अब वो इंपोर्टेंट क्यों है यह आप ही
बताओगे क्यों वई इट इ इंपोर्टेंट पहले बात
तो मुझे य बताइए रोबोट्स फाइल होती क्या
है और सेकंड क्वेश्चन मेरा यह है कि रोबोट
डटी एक्सटी फाइल है किसी भी पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर के लिए इंपोर्टेंट क्यों है बताइए
इसको हम फाइंड आउट करते हैं और एक चीज है
हमें जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिली थी पहले अभी इसको
हम वो करते
हैं रोटस डटी
एकटी यस अभी यहां पर हमें कुछ खास
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली
देखो यह रहा हमें सब यह कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली
है नहीं रोबोट डटी एक्टी जो फाइल होती है
वह किस लिए होती है
यस जो रोबोट डटी एक्सटी है उस फाइल को
क्रॉलर के लिए बनाया जाता है ताकि हम
क्रॉलर को यह बता सके कि मेरी वेबसाइट के
अंदर मैं क्या अलाव करना चाहता हूं क्रॉल
करने के लिए क्या डिस अलाव करना चाहता हूं
एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर हमारे लिए इसलिए
इंपॉर्टेंट है कि वहां पर हमें यह
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है कि क्रॉलर को क्या
क्रोल करने के लिए अलाउड है और क्या डिस
अलाउ है डिस अलाव मतलब हो सकता है कि वहां
पर कुछ ऐसे इंपोर्टेंट डायरेक्टरीज हैं या
ऐसे इंपोर्टेंट वेब पेजेस हैं या फाइल्स
हैं जो क्रॉलर को अलाउड नहीं है लेकिन हम
क्या कर सकते हैं मैनुअली उसको क्या कर
सकते हैं ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं रीच आउट
कर सकते हैं हो सकता है कि वहां पर विदाउट
एनी सिक्योरिटी कोई वल्नरेबल हो वो फाइल
हम एक्सेस कर पाए क्योंकि क्रॉलर को उसको
परमिशन नहीं है बट हम मैनुअल तरीके से उस
उस फाइल पर उस डायरेक्टरी पर जाकर उस
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन को फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कर सकते हैं और दिस इज वन ऑफ द
बेस्ट वे टू फाइंड आउट द मैनुअल टेक्निक
यू दिस इज द बेस्ट मैनुअल टेक्निक थ्रो
व्हिच वी कैन फाइंड आउट डायरेक्टरीज एंड
फाइल्स इंफॉर्मेशन ओके तो एक सबसे बेस्ट
तरीका लेकिन यहां पर हमने कुछ भी नहीं
मिला यहां पर हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिला जस्ट
एक ये एक ये वर्ड मिला है चलो इसको अब ये
हो सकता है कोई
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
ओके नाउ यह मेरा आई एड्रेस है तो
101.9
6108 यस सिंपली हिट एंटर यह देखिए नॉट
फाउंड द रिक्वेस्टेड यूआरएल वाज नॉट फाउंड
ऑन दि सर्वर ओके अचे
2.4.41 वनटू
सर्वर इस चीज से आपको क्या समझ में आ रहा
है कि यह क्या चीज़
है क्या यह इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे लिए
इंपॉर्टेंट है हेल्पफुल है या नहीं है यह
इंफॉर्मेशन
बताइए यह अपाचे सर्वर है यह उसका वर्जन है
और साथ में यह भी हमें प्रूव कर रहा है कि
अगर हमारे पास हम सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
कर रहे थे अगर वहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
मिलती तो यहां से भी हमें क्रॉस चेक हो
गया किय एक लिनक्स मशीन है लेकिन साथ में
एक अपाचे सर्वर है उसका वर्जन 2.4.41 है
तो क्या यह हमारे लिए हेल्पफुल हो सकता है
इट इज हेल्पफुल इंफॉर्मेशन और
नॉट अगर यह हमारे लिए हेल्पफुल है कैसे
क्योंकि वर्जन स्पेसिफिक हम क्या कर सकते
हैं एक्सप्लोइट फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं अचय सर्वर के अंदर 2.4.41 वर्जन
की हम एक्सप्लोर फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
कर सकते हैं अगर यह
वर्जन वल्नरेबल से एक्सप्लोइट है किसी भी
पर्टिकुलर वनबिल से एक्सप्लोइटेबल है तो
आप क्या कर सकते हो एक्सप्लोइट को यूज
करके उसको फिक्स करके आप इस मशीन पे
एक्सेस गेन कर सकते हैं दैट इज वई दिस इज
आल्सो ए मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन तो
अभी हमें हमें एक काम करना चाहिए सबसे
पहले एक फाइल क्रिएट करो जहां पर हम हर एक
इंफॉर्मेशन को क्या करेंगे नोट डाउन
करेंगे चलो अभी मैं इसको ज़ूम कर देता हूं
ये
रहा इसका साइज बढ़ा देते हैं अभी हम से एक
एक आदत बना लो कि जब भी आप पन टेस्टिंग कर
रहे हो कि कौन-कौन से स्टेप आप परफॉर्म कर
रहे हो आपने क्या स्टेप कहां पर क्या
परफॉर्म किया है क्या क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको मिली यह काफी हेल्पफुल होता है आपके
लिए जब आपको क्या करना है किसी भी पेन
टेस्टिंग की रिपोर्ट बनानी है क्योंकि
वहां पर आपको स्क्रीनशॉट भी चाहिए कौन सी
इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे आपने गेट इन की कौन सा
टूल यूज किया क्या टेक्निक यूज की कैसे
अपने पासवर्ड को फाइंड आउट किया और कहां
पर कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन मिली थी सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास जैसे मेरे पास यहां
पर आप आ ये इंफॉर्मेशन कंट्रोल व यहां पर
मैं क्या करता हूं ये रहा एक इंफॉर्मेशन
ये है दूसरा मेरे पास ये है अ से 2.4.1 ये
है मेरे पास इंफॉर्मेशन इसको भी मैं कॉपी
करता हूं और सिंपली आई विल सेव दिस
इंफॉर्मेशन टू फाइल और एक और इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली थी अभी हम इसको गो बैक करते हैं हम
robot.txt प चलते हैं चलो इसको बैक किया
नाउ ये रहा राइट क्लिक व्यू पेज सोर्स और
एक और इंफॉर्मेशन यूजर नेम कौन सा हमारा
यह रहा ये हमारा यूजर नेम है दिस वन इज द
ववर यूजर नेम तो ये तीन इंपोर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन हमें मिल गई है किसी भी फाइल
के बारे में ओके तो किसी भी टारगेट के
बारे
में या एज पर योर रिक्वायरमेंट आप कोई भी
यूज कर सकते हो जो आपको सूटेबल हो तो यह
था हमारा मैनुअल तरीका एन्यूमरेशन का या
जहां पर हमने रोबोट डटी एकटी फाइल को
फाइंड आउट किया जिसके अंदर कोई भी हमा
हमें वैल्युएबल इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली
दूसरा हमने एसेट डायरेक्टरी को क्रॉस चेक
करके देखा वहां पर भी हमें कुछ ज्यादा
वैल्यूएबल्स
टाइम टू ऑटोमेट अवर प्रोसेस उस प्रोसेस
में हम टूल का यूज करने वाले हैं डरबस्टर
आप वैसे तो डायरेक्टरी अब डरबस्टर है
डरबस्टर एक ऐसा टूल है ग्राफिकल यूजर टूल
है जो मोस्ट कॉमन टूल है जो आपको
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के काम आता है
आप क्या करते हो कि एक वर्डलिस्ट प्रोवाइड
करते हो इस टूल को उस वर्डलिस्ट के बेस पर
आप क्या करते हो कि डायरेक्टरीज और फाइल्स
की फाइल्स को फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करते हो किसी भी वेबसाइट के अंदर वैसे
बहुत सारे टूल्स अवेलेबल है जैसे गो
बस्टर्स है फज है डब्लू फज है बहुत सारे
टूल्स है जिन के थ्रू आप फजिंग और
डायरेक्ट ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करते हो लेकिन हम
सबसे पहले हम आज सीखने वाले हैं मोस्ट
कॉमन टूल है जिसका नाम डरबस्टर है उसको
कैसे यूज़ करते हैं उसके थ्रू हम कैसे
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कर सकते हैं डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग वो आज हम सीखने वाले हैं
कैसे इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हैं किसी भी डायरेक्टरी की या किसी
भी फाइल्स की या किसी भी वेब पेज की
अकॉर्डिंग टू द वेबसाइट किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट के लिए उसके लिए हमारे पास एक गुड
एक अच्छी वर्ड लिस्ट होनी चाहिए और बिफोर
ब्रूट फोर्स आपको हर एक मैनुअल तरीके आपको
अपला अपना लेने चाहिए ताकि
आप श्यर हो जाए कि अभी मुझे और कोई
इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिल रही अभी
मुझे मेरे पास लास्ट ऑप्शन इ द ब्रूट
फोर्स ओके तो एक काम करते हैं अभी गो बैक
टू अवर टर्मिनल अभी हम क्या करते हैं डर
बस्टर को यूज करने वाले हैं ओके डर बस्टर
को तो उसको यूज करने के लिए सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है यह बाय डिफॉल्ट आपकी मशीन
में देखने को मिलता है तो डर
बस्टर यह रहा और सिंपली हिट एंटर करना है
अभी यह
रहा यस आप गो बस्टर को भी यूज कर सकते ड
बस्टर को भी यूज कर सकते हो आज हम डरबस्टर
को यूज करेंगे कल हम गो बस्टर को यूज कर
लेंगे नो इशू अभी लब समाप्त नहीं हुई है
कंट्रोल शिफ प्लस यह जूम होगा क्या इसको
ऑप्शन को हम क्या करते हैं अभी यह
रहा एक काम इसको हम जूम स्ट्रेच नहीं कर
सकते देखिए आपको इससे काम चलाना पड़े इसको
जूम नहीं कर सकते किसी को अगर इसका आईडिया
जूम करने का तो प्लीज देखिए एक
बार यह रहा इतना ही जूम कर सकते हैं हम
इससे ज्यादा नहीं कर सकते तो ओके तो सबसे
पहले आपको टारगेट यूआरएल में आपको क्या
प्रोवाइड करना है कंप्लीट फुल प्र कॉल के
साथ में टारगेट यूआरएल प्रोवाइड करना तो
कैसे एटीटीपी डबल कॉलन फॉरव स्ल 10
डट
1096 यही था हमारा एडस 108 यह हमारा क्या
है आईपी एड्रेस है तो यह हमारा फुल यूआरएल
है एटीटीपी 10 उसके बाद
101.9 6.10 यहां पर हमें क्या गया फुल
यूआरएल प्रोवाइड करना है ओके यहां पर क्या
करना फुल यूआरएल आपको आपने प्रोवाइड करना
है अभी बाय डिफॉल्ट टी यूज कर रहा है तो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है नेक्स्ट आपको मेंशन
करना वर्क मेथड मतलब आप ओनली गेट
रिक्वेस्ट करना चाहते हो या स्विच
ऑटोमेटिक स्विच हैड गेट मैं ऑटोमेटिक
स्विच करना चाहता हूं नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स अभी
नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स का मतलब क्या होता है कि
यह आपकी मशीन में पलि जम ऐड करता है मतलब
जितने नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स आप रखोगे उतने
ज्यादा आपको रिजल्ट देखने को मिलेंगे उतना
ज्यादा फास्ट आपका ये टूल काम करेगा उतने
जल्दी आपकी मशीन से टूल अपना काम फिनिश कर
लेगा लेकिन जो नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स हैं वो
डिपेंड करते हैं आपकी लैपटॉप या आपकी मशीन
कॉन्फिन के ऊपर इसके लिए आपके पास एक गुड
सीपीय कॉन्फिन होनी चाहिए सो दैट कि आप एज
योर रिक्वायरमेंट नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स को आप
यूज कर सको लेकिन अगर आपके पास एक
स्विचेबल सीपीयू नहीं है गुड कॉन्फिन नहीं
है और आपने अगर वर्चुअल बॉक्स के अंदर
कानेस को यूज कर रहे हो और उसको अच्छे
सारी आपने कॉन्फिन को प्र नहीं अच्छे खासी
रम को नहीं दिया है तो आपको सिंपली क्या
करना है बाय डिफॉल्ट थ 10 थ्रेड है उन्हीं
को ही यूज करना है अदर वाइज क्या करेगा
आपका जो काली लिनेक्स है वो लैग करेगा देन
उसके बाद आप क्या करोगे स्लेक्ट स्कैनिंग
टाइप किस टाइप की ब्रूट फोर्स आप परफॉर्म
करना चाहते हो लिस्ट बेस ब्रूट फोर्स
परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो या प्योर ब्रूट
फोर्स लिस्ट बेस ब्रूट फोर्स में क्या
होता है कि आप एक लिस्ट प्रोवाइड करते हो
एक वर्ड लिस्ट देते हो और उसी वर्ड लिस्ट
को क्या करेगा आपकी वेबसाइट के अगेंस्ट
चेक करेगा प्योर ब्रूट फोर्स में क्या
होता है कि प्योर ब्रूट फोर्स में
कॉमिनेशन ट्राई करता है जैसे कि फॉर
एग्जांपल मेरे पास एक न डिज का पासवर्ड है
जिसका पासवर्ड क्या है मेरे पास 789 है बट
अगर मैं उसम प्योर ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई
करूंगा तो कैसे करूंगा कि ऐसे ट्राई करा
है कैरेक्टर बाय कैरेक्टर वर्ड बाय वर्ड
डिजिट बाय डिजिट कैसे करे 00 0 1 00 2 003
ऐसे वन बाय ये क्या करेगा डिजिट को शिफ्ट
करेगा और प्योर ब्रूट फोर्स करेगा प्योर
ब्रूट फोर्स में क्या होता है आपका सीपीयू
भी लगता है और आपका जीपीयू दोनों चाहिए
आपका प्योर ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के टाइम और साथ
में क्या है कि आपके जो मशीनस है उसकी
पावर ज्यादा लगती है और साथ में आपको काफी
टाइम लगता है प्योर ब्रूट फोर्स में तो इट
इज वेरी इंपोर्टेंट अभी हम क्या करने वाले
हैं लिस्ट बेस ब्रूट फोर्स करने वाले हैं
नेक्स्ट जब हम लिस्ट बेस ब्रूट फोर्स
परफॉर्म करते हैं तो लिस्ट बेस ब्रूट
फोर्स परफॉर्म करने के लिए हमारे पास एक
वर्ड लिस्ट होनी चाहिए अगर आप चाहो तो
वर्डलिस्ट कहां से डाउनलोड कर सकते हो अभी
के लिए मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि आप वर्ड
लिस्ट यूज कर सकते हो वैसे सेक लिस्ट होती
है आप देखोगे तो यह
रहा सेक लिस्ट सेक लिस्ट एक वर्ड लिस्ट
होती है आप इसको भी यहां पर आपकी य
डायरेक्टरी वाली वर्ड लिस्ट नहीं देखने को
मिलेगी तो यह अभी देखो आप इसमें फजिंग के
लेटेड बहुत सारी वर्ड लिस्ट देखने को
मिलेगी इट इ वेरी गुड यहां से आप वर्ड
लिस्ट उठा सकते हो दूसरा क्या है कि हम जो
वर्ड लिस्ट यूज करने वाले हैं हम क्या
करेंगे डर बस्टर वर्डलिस्ट हम क्या करेंगे
ड बस्टर
वर्ड लिस्ट को परफॉर्म कर और इसकी बाय
डिफॉल्ट जो वर्ड लिस्ट है सिंपली क्लिक
करेंगे गेट अप लिंक पर तो यहां पर यह है
आपकी य र देखो यहां पर यह क्या है अचे एनम
डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट यह मीयम t एकटी स्लटी
एक्टी तो अभी मैं जो यूज करने वाला हूं
डायरेक्टली रि 2.3 मम सिंपली यहां पर
क्लिक करना है क्लिक करने के बाद आपको
डाउनलोड ऑप्शन पर जाना है जैसे इसको
डाउनलोड करोगे और इस इसको आपको ओपन करना
ओपन करने के बाद स्टार्टिंग में कुछ
कमेंट्स हो हो उन कमेंट्स को आपने क्या
करना है रिमूव करना है देन उसके बाद आपके
वर्ड्स की यह क्या है एक वर्ड लिस्ट बन
जाएगी सेव करना है उसके बाद इस टूल्स में
ऐड करना है जैसे कि मैं अभी यूज करने वाला
हूं यह रहा दिस वन वे इ द य रहा डरबस्टर
अभी ब्राउज करेंगे गो टू ब्राउज एंड मैं
यूज करने वाला हूं डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट 2.3
मयम टीटी लिस्ट को मैंने यहां पर सेलेक्ट
किया और उसके बाद किसी भी ऑप्शन को आपको
चेंज करने की जरूरत नहीं है बाय डिफॉल्ट
इसको टिक रहने दीजिए कि बट फोर्स
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स फाइल्स बी रिकर्स
और ये बिल्कुल और उसके बाद हमने क्या करना
है डायरेक्टली स्टार्ट द स्कैन आपने अपनी
स्कैनिंग स्टार्ट कर देनी है उसके बाद गो
टू योर रिजल्ट टैब और आपको वेट करना
है यहां तक सबको आई होप की एंजॉय आ रहा
होगा एंजॉयमेंट लग रहा होगा बोर नहीं हो
रहे होगे अभी हम क्या कर रहे हैं
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कर रहे यहां पर
एक चीज देखिए देखिए लॉगइन ड पीएपी पहले
नहीं था फाइल आपको देखने को मिल
डायरेक्टरी असेट हमें पता था अट के अंदर
बप मन ज हमें पता था जेक मन जस हमें पता
था आइकन नाम से एक और नई डायरेक्टरी देखने
को मिली है उसके बाद पोर्टल पीएपी दो आपने
आपको क्या है फाइल देखने को मिली है इनका
देखो स्टेटस रिस्पांस
कोड किसी को पता है कि यह जो कोड्स आपको
देखने को मिल रहे हैं रिस्पांस कोड सब
इनको आइडेंटिफिकेशन
मतलब क्या होता है और 403 का मतलब क्या
होता है और 302 का मतलब क्या होता है
एवरीवन अवेयर अबाउट दिस रिस्पांस
कोड सभी को पता
है सभी को रिस्पांस कोड देखने आते
हैं बताइए
अब फॉर एपल देखि ये है इसको राइट क्लिक
करता हूं ओपन इन ब्राउजर य
रहा पता नहीं कहां पर ओपन किया बट इसने
ओपन नहीं किया अभी तक ओके नो इशू नो इशू
हम इसको क्या करते हैं
अभी कॉपी यूआरएल और सिंपली आप क्या करो
क्लिक और यहां पर देखिए पेस्ट और लॉगइन ड
पीएपी यह रहा अब यहां पर आपको एक लॉगिन
पेज देखने को मिल रहा है यह
रहा यहां पर आपका लॉगिन पेज है लॉगइन ड
पीएपी और एक एक काम और करते हैं हम पोटल ड
पीएपी में क्या था देखो पोर्टल ड पीएपी
में क्या था कॉपी यरल देन उसके बाद यह रहा
पेस्ट एंड गो यह रहा अभी देखो पोर्टल ड
पीएपी भी आपको रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है किसके
ऊपर लॉगइन ड पीएपी और लॉगइन का पेज है यह
क्या एक लॉगइन पेज है यह आपका एक लॉग इन
पेज है प्लीज बताइए यार क्या हो गया आप
लोग शायद मे भी यू आर गेटिंग
बोर यस तो अभी हमारे पास एक बात बताइए
यूजर नेम तो है हमारे पास
ओके तो हमारे पास यूजर नेम है हमारे पास
यूजर नेम कहां है यह रहा देखो तब तक व
कंप्लीट हो जाए यह रहा यूजर नेम और सिंपली
हम क्या करते हैं अभी कॉपी एंड पेस्ट किया
अभी हम यहां पर पेस्ट किया यूजर नेम है
अभी हमें क्या करना है यहां पर ट्रायल एंड
हिट ट्राल एंड हिट फॉर एग्जांपल कैसे कौन
स ट्राइल एट हम परफॉर्म करेंगे जैसे कि
मैं एक बार ट्राई करता हूं इधर कि कौन-कौन
से यूजर नेम ट्राई करता हूं मिनट जस्ट हम
ट्राई कर सकते क्या ट्राई कर सकते हैं आप
लोग को जो लगता है हम ट्राई करते हैं
बताइए जैसे मैं यही ट्राई कर लेता एक
तो
लॉगिन यह रहा इनवैलिड यूजर नेम ओके कोई
नहीं अभी मैं ट्राई करता हूं एडमिन एक
एडमिन यूजर नेम होता है नो वैलिड लॉगइन
उसके बाद मैं ट्राई क्या कर सकता हूं हमें
एक यूजर नेम मिला था कौन सा ये रहा मोटी
चलो हम मोटी ट्राई कर लेते हैं हो सकता है
कंप्लीट यूजर नेम हो यह पासवर्ड हो तो यह
ओके तो हम सिंपली क्या करते हैं यह
रहा पेस्ट लॉग इन हमने लॉगिन किया नो आई
एम नॉट एबल टू लॉग इन तो क्या गेस हो सकता
है एडमिन कर लिया हमने और एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडी एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हमने ट्राई कर लिया नो
मतलब एक चीज तो यहां पर शर है कि लॉगिन
पेज रेट लिमिट यहां पर अप्लाई नहीं की गई
है ओके एडमिन एडमिन गुड हम ट्राई करते हैं
ओके ब ओके बी
यू आर आर आर पी ओके हम ट्राई करते हैं
चलो बी यू आर आर आर प हिट एंटर नो दिस इ
इनवैलिड ओके
एडमिन रेट टूथ
नोट क्या एक चज ट्राई करते हैं हम नहीं
अभी हम एसक्यूएल नहीं ट्राई करेंगे मैं
आपको स्टेप बाय स्टेप लेकर जाऊंगा ओके
क्या एक चीज ट्राई करते हैं हमने रोबोट
डटी एक्सटी फाइल से एक वैल्यू मिली थी
क्या उसको ट्राई आउट करके
देखें क्या उसको हम ट्राई आउट करके
देखें
बताइए चलो उसको ट्राई आउट करते हैं यह
देखिए यह थी एक वैल्यू और यह
देखो कॉपी एंड पेस्ट यह रही और हिट एंटर
नाउ वी आर सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन देखिए मुझे
नहीं पता था इसका यह पासवर्ड है ट्रस्ट मी
ओके या आपको नहीं आपको भी नहीं पता था बट
क्या है कि यह हिट एल ट्रायल था चाहे तो
हम यहां पर क्या कर सकते थे ब्रूट फोर्स
कर सकते लॉगिन पेज को ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते
विद द हेल्प ऑफ मेटा या अदर टूल्स हम कर
सकते थे बट अभी हम ट ट्रायल कर रहे थे जो
भी इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास अवेलेबल थी थी
यूजर नेम था रैंडम पासवर्ड हमने ट्राई किए
उसके बाद robot.txt फाइल में एक हमें एक
वैल्यू मिली थी वो ट्राई किया लेकिन व
क्या मिली इसका पासवर्ड मिला लेकिन यह कोई
एक लॉजिक नहीं है कि आपको यह कोई भी
स्पेसिफिक रूल नहीं है कि जहां पर आपको
हमें robot.txt फाइल के अंदर पासवर्ड
यूजर्स के पासवर्ड मिलेंगे क्योंकि
robot.txt फाइल वो कॉलर्स के लिए है और
robot.txt फाइल के अंदर कभी भी आपको
पासवर्ड देखने को नहीं मिलेंगे क्योंकि यह
एक सीटीएफ बेस्ड लैब थी ये ये आपको हमेशा
क्या करते है जो सीटीएफ लेस आपको हैबिल
बनाती है आपकी आदत आपको आदत डालती है कि
आपके पास जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है
उसको आपको रियल लाइफ में जब आप पन टेस्ट
करोगे उनको कैसे हिट एंड ट्रायल बेस प यूज
करना है तो जितने भी आप ट्राई हैक म की
हैक द बस आईन ई या अटैक डिफेंस या आपके
वलन हब जितने भी लैप्स आप ट्राई करते हो
उन सभी का मोटो यही है कि आपको हैबिल
बनाना आपकी आदत बनाना कि आप अवेलेबल
इंफॉर्मेशन को किस तरीके से यूज कर सकते
हो रियल वर्ल्ड में देन उसके बाद लास्ट
ऑप्शंस होते हैं फिर आपके सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग्स होते हैं फिर आपके ऑप्शंस
होते हैं आपके ब्रूट फोर्स होते हैं और
फर्द आप क्या कि फिजिकली ट्राई करते हो
बिल्डिंग के अंदर तो वह दूसरे तरीके अलग
होते हैं बट यह आपको एक हैबिट बना के देते
हैं कि आपको कैसे ट्राई आउट करना है चीजों
को ओके तो वी आर सक्सेसफुली इन अब यहां पर
देखिए हम क्लिक करके देखते हैं रिक पोर्टल
कुछ ऑप्शन देखो पोर्शन पर नाड पीएपी एक और
हमें य पर फाइल मिली इसको भी हम सेव कर
सकते हैं देन क्रिएचर्स नाड पीएपी पोशन
नाड पीएपी बथ क्लोन नोट्स यहां पर भी आपको
कुछ देखने को नहीं मिला लेकिन लिक
पोर्टल्स कुछ नहीं कमांड्स यहां पर आपको
कमांड में देखना यहां पर कुछ आपको ऐसे र
कुछ कमांड पैनल टाइप का देखने को लग रहा
है अगर मुझे कमांड देखने को मिल फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने एलस किया हिट एंटर ओ वाओ
तो अभी देखो यहां पर कुछ हमें डायरेक्टरीज
फाइल देखने को मिली robot.txt सर्च आउट कर
चुके हैं
portal.in in.php यही है index.htm .
php.net यह फाइल आपने देखी होगी देखा आपने
यह
सब तो अभी मैं एक बार पीडब्ल्यूडी करता
हूं प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी देखो
वार डब्लू डब्लू एचटीएमएल अभी एक चीज मुझे
यह बताओ कि मैं मुझे कैसे पता चलेगा कि
मैं य पर कौन सी कमांड यूज करनी है बताइए
मुझे हाउ शुड आई नो कि च मशीन कमांड आई
विल यूज कौन सी कमांड में यूज
करूंगा बताइए बताइए बताइए
बताओ बताओ बताओ मुझे कैसे पता चला कि मुझे
अभी पीडब्लूडी यूज करनी है क्यों क्योंकि
हमारे पास जो अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन
थी वह इंफॉर्मेशन क्या थी कि हमारी एक
लिनक्स मशीन है हमारी यह एक लिनक्स मशीन
है ये इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास थी इसलिए हम
क्या कर रहे हैं नक् की कमांड ट्राई कर
रहे
अभी यहां पर एक चीज बता देता हूं यह क्या
है आज करोगे लैब को फिनिश या कल करें
बताओ आज ही फिनिश करें लैब को या कल करें
बताओ
एवरीवन जिसकी जितनी ज्यादा वोट होंगी उतना
आज हम वो
करेंगे ओके ओके
ओके कंटिन्यूएशन टूट जाएगा तो एक काम करते
हैं हम कि यह लैब की वलन बिलिटी आपको बता
देता हूं कि कैसे आपने
सक्सेसफुली आपको फ्लैग मिलेंगे लेकिन
इसमें कौन सी वनबिल है वो उस वनटी को
एक्सप्लेन कल कर द क्लास में
चलेगा बताओ बताओ मुझे सभी से आंसर
चाहिए देखो यहां पर जो व टी मिली आपको मैं
बताता हूं आपको जो वनटी मिली है आपकी य
कमांड इंजेक्शन वल्नरेबल है यह काफी
सीरियस वल्नरेबल है और अकॉर्डिंग टू ओवास
टॉप 10
2021 यह जो पी3 है जो वनेटिव नंबर थ्री है
a3 है उसका जो इंजेक्शन वटी है उसका एक
पार्ट है आपका कमांड इंजेक्शन वनटी इसको
आप सेल कमांड इंजेक्शन भी बोल सकते हो या
आप इसको ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कमांड इंजेक्शन
भी बोल सकते हो यह कौन सी है आपकी
कमांड इंजेक्शन वल्नरेबल है ठीक है तो
कमांड इंजेक्शन वटी क्या होती है इसको मैं
कल एक्सप्लेन करता हूं बट इस वनटी का
फायदा कैसे उठाते हैं यह अभी आपको मैं
परफॉर्म करके दिखाता हूं लेकिन कमांड
इंजेक्शन वटी के बारे में नेक्स्ट क्लास
में बता दूंगा बिफोर स्टार्टिंग नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक या आपको अगर मैं नोट्स प्रोवाइड कर
दूंगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है ओके तो अभी यहां बताइए ओके पीडब्ल्यू
प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टर मेरी क्या है
वार ड्ड एचटीएमएल ओके वार डब्लू डब्
एचटीएमएल मेरी एक डायरेक्टरी है तो ओके
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं एलएस करता हूं फिर
से एलएस किया तो मेरे पास सुपर सक्रेट
पिकल इडिट t एकटी है तो अब मुझे इसको रीड
करना है तो कौन सी कमांड मैं यूज करूंगा
व्हिच कमांड आई विल यूज क्योंकि एक कमांड
इंजेक्शन वटी इसके अंदर है और मुझे क्या
करता है जो भी मैं यहां पर
अपने वेबसाइट के अंदर कोई भी कमांड में
एग्जीक्यूट करूंगा व सारी कमांड कहां पर
बैक एंड में जो सर्वर है पा सर्वर उसके
ऊपर डायरेक्टली एग्जीक्यूट कर रही है यहां
पर इनपुट फिल्ट्रेशन की कमी है आपको हिंट
दे दिया यहां पर इनपुट फिल्ट्रेशन की कमी
है कैसे ओके कैट चलो हम कैट का यूज करते
हैं दिस वन इज अवर कैट कॉपी
एंड यहां पर कैट
क कैट और यह रहा यह रहा हिट
एंटर कमांड
डिसेबल कमांड
डिसेबल अभी हम क्या करें एकको एकको को हम
यूज नहीं कर
सकते व्हाट इज द अल्टरनेटिव ऑफ द कैट
कमांड रिसर्च करो जल्दी बताओ व्हाट इज द
अल्टरनेटिव ऑफ द कैट
कमांड वी आई वी आई आपका एडिटर
ननो नहीं ननो आपको हा ननो ओके ननो फाइल को
करने काम आता बट कोई दिक्कत नहीं ननो
कंट्रोल व हिट
एंटर नो कमांड
डिसेबल्ड गेट
नो यस वेरी गुड देखो अभी किसी ने बोला सर
हैड कर सकते हैं तो ओके हैड करेंगे
हम हैड कंट्रोल व हिट एंटर नो कमांड
डिसेबल बैट ओके हम बैट करके दिखाते हैं
आपके सामने बैट कमांड को हमने यूज किया
कंट्रोल
व देखो बेट कमांड किया काम नहीं किया ओके
और मोर कमांड बोल रहे हैं लोग को लो मोर
कमांड को हमने यूज किया और कंट्रोल व यह
रहा ट
एंटर कमांड डिसेबल अभी हम क्या करें
कैट कमांड डिसेबल
है यस एक चीज और ट्राई करते हैं
लेस लेस कमांड को हम यूज करते हैं लेस और
कंट्रोल व हिट एंटर नाउ सक्सेसफुली वी गट
द आंसर यह रहा मिस्टर मसक हेयर दिस इज आवर
वन आंसर कॉपी करते हैं हम इसको और इसको
अपने पैड में रखते हैं इसमें नोटपैड में
ये रहा कंट्रोल व एक आंसर हमें मिल गया
नाउ अभी यहां पर क्या है कि आपको समझना
चाहिए यहां पर क्या है कि यूजर्स ने थोड़ा
सा लेवल आपका हार्ड करने के लिए बिल्कुल
लिटिल लेवल बहुत सारी कमांड को डिसेबल कर
दिया है मतलब ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हार्ड निंग
का यूज किया है बिल्कुल लो लेवल पर हार्ड
लेवल पर यूज नहीं किया है यहां पर लिनक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हार्ड निंग का यूज किया
है कुछ कमांड्स को ब्लॉक कर दिया है सो
दैट कि आपको सोचने पर मजबूर किया जा रहा
है कि अगर मेरी इन बिटवीन पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग या रियल लाइफ में अगर यह कमांड
काम नहीं कर रही होगी तो मुझे अल्टरनेटिव
कमांड्स के बारे में भी एक चीट चट होनी
चाहिए सो दैट की ये कमांड काम नहीं कर
दूसरी कमांड डेफिनेटली काम करे ओके यही
चीज यहां पर हुई लेस्ट कमांड के थ्रू हमने
फ्लैग मिल गया ओके एलएस अभी फिर से क्या
अभी क्लू डटी एक्टी को हम क्या करते हैं
लेस कमांड के थ्रू देखते हैं लेस कमांड
क्लू डटी एक्टी लेस उसके बाद क्लू डॉट t
एक्टी टी एक् अब इसको हम फाइंड आउट करते
देखो यहां पर क्या मिला लुक अराउंड द फाइल
सिस्टम फॉर अदर इंग्रेडिएंट्स अभी आप जो
फाइंड आउट करना चाहते हो व आपको यहां नहीं
मिलेगा आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा और रिसर्च
करना पड़ेगा तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं यह
रहा सीडी अभी मैं होम डायरेक्टरी अंदर
चलते हैं सीडी होम य र हिट
एंटर अब फिर से मैं एलस करता हूं यह
देखो नहीं सीडी होम डायरेक्टरी किया मेलस
किया नो
वापस से मैं इधर आ गया मतलब कुछ भी शो
नहीं किया नाउ व्हाट कैन वी डू अभी हम
क्या
करें अभी मैं कुछ भी करा हू सीडी रूट करता
हूं फॉर एग्जांपल देखो सीडी मैंने यहां पर
किया रूट और हिट
एंटर फिर से मैं एलस करता
हूं और घूम फिर के उधर ही आ गया तो इस केस
में हम क्या करेंगे नहीं नहीं सीडी रूट भी
नहीं काम कर रहा देखो यस सीडी
रूट हिट एंटर और फिर से मैं एलस कर रहा
हूं यह रहा घूम फर के उधर ही आ रहे
बारबार तो व्ट शुड आई डू इन ट
केस पीडब्ल्यूडी ओके पीडब्ल्यूडी तो हमने
बता दिया ना प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
आपके वार डब्लू डब्लू एचटीएमएल है बट क्या
है कि यह बारबार घूम फिर के यहां पर क्या
है कुछ हार्ड निंग का यूज किया और हमें
घुमा फिरा के धर ले आता है व्ट इ
अल्टरनेटिव ऑप्शन
अभी हम क्या
करें नहीं काम कर
रहा क्या हम दो कमांड को एक साथ जोड़ सकते
हैं क्या हम दो कमांड को एक साथ जोड़ सकते
हैं बताइए क्या हम दो कमांड को एक साथ
जोड़ सकते
हैं कैसे जोड़ सकते हैं बताइए मुझे अगर दो
कमांड को एक साथ जोड़ना हो ओके यूजिंग पिप
और और और बताइए
कैसे अगर आप लोगों को लिनक्स की नॉलेज
होगी थोड़ी सी भी आप कर
पाओगे यस एंड एंड का भी यूज कर सकते
हैं चलो सेमी कोलन का यूज कर सकते हैं ओके
तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं सीडी चलो सीडी
होम करते हैं हम सीडी होम उसके बाद हम
क्या करते हैं सेमीकलन उसके बाद एलएस और
हिट एंटर ये देखिए रिक एंड ओबन टू नाउ वी
गोट सक्सेसफुल हमें क्या है अभी यहां पर
हम सक्सेसफुली हमने इस कमांड को एंटर कर
लिया मतलब क्या कि अगर मैं सिंगल कमांड को
रन कर रहा हूं तो यह क्या करता है घुमा
फिरा के मुझे उसी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर ले
आता है अगर मैं दो कमांड को एक साथ जोड़ता
हूं तो मतलब क्या कर सकता हूं मैं
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर पा रहा हूं तो
ओके कोई बात नहीं अभी मुझे रिक के अंदर की
इंफॉर्मेशन देखनी है उसके मुझे कमांड कैसे
बनानी पड़ेगी मैं बनाऊंगा ओके कैसे
बताओ
सीडी स्लश
होम स्लश
रिक उसके बाद सेमीकलन एल एस उसके बाद हाइ
फन एल भी एल ए भी कर सकते हैं हाइ फन एल ए
कर सकते हैं ओके एल ए और ट एंटर नाउ रिक
के अंदर क्या क्या आपका ये रहा डायरेक्टरी
य एक ही फाइल है कौन सी आपकी सेकंड इन
ग्रेडिएंट्स
सेकंड इन ग्रेडिएंट्स आपकी एक फाइल मिल गी
सेकंड इंग्रेडिएंट्स चलो अभी इसको मुझे
कैट करना है अग इसके इंफॉर्मेशन मुझे
देखने कैसे कमांड बताओ जल्दी से
मुझे फटाफट मुझे जल्दी से कमांड बताओ कैसे
करना होगा
बताइए जल्दी से जल्दी से जल्दी से कमांड
क्या बनाऊंगा मैं कि मैं इस फाइल को रीड
आउट कर
पाऊ लेटस ना नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नोनो
कोई तो अच्छा आंसर दो यार नो नो नो नो नो
कोई भी अगर एक भी इस कमांड के लिए हम यूज
करना पड़ेगा लेस कमांड हमें पता है लेस
कमांड काम करती है फुल पाथ
होम उसके बाद रिक होम और रिक आर आई सी के
रिक उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है सेकंड इन
ग्रेडिएंट को यूज करना है लो सेकंड
इंग्रेडिएंट्स
कॉपी एंड
पेस्ट कॉपी पेस्ट किया देन उसके बाद
सिंपली हिट एंटर
ना हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिला अभी क्यों नहीं
मिला मुझे
बताइए अभी मुझे क्यों नहीं मिली जो
इंफॉर्मेशन थी जो इसके अंदर फ्लैग था मुझे
वह क्यों नहीं
मिला बिल्कुल बेसिक क्वेश्चन है अगर आपने
लिनक्स पढ़ा होगा लिनक्स में ध्यान दिया
होगा हिंट आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं जब
भी आप कोई भी फाइल क्रिएट करते हो और या
नक् अंदर जो अभी आप टर्मिनल में कमांड
टाइप करते हो यह मैंने बैस में ही पढ़ाया
हुआ है तो एक हिंट है ये तो क्या कारण है
इधर नहीं नहीं दो कमांड यूज करनी नहीं
होगी यह कमांड सही
है यस बिल्कुल मुखरजी वाइट स्पेसिंग
क्योंकि जब आपने लास्ट कमांड जो टाइप की
थी कौन सी थी यह वाली थी लास्ट कमांड तो
हमने टाइप की थी
लेस ये रही ये जो हमने कमांड टाइप की थी
इसमें क्या था कि लेस ओके यह एक कमांड
काउंट की टर्मिनल ने बट यह वाइट स्पेस
क्या है वाइट स्पेस के कारण क्या हो गया
यह एरर क्रिएट होगी तो मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा सिंगल कोट में इसको मेंशन करना
पड़ेगा जब भी हम क्या करते हैं वाइट स्पेस
सेपरेटेड फाइल नेम देते हैं तो उस केस में
हम क्या करते हैं सिंगल कोट मेंशन करते
हैं फाइल का तो अभी सिंपली हिट एंटर अब ये
देखिए वन जे यर हमें मिल गया वन जरी टियर
तो सेकंड फ्लैग भी हमें मिल गया ये रहा
हमारे पास ये हमारा सेकंड फ्लैग है नाउ
अभी हमें थर्ड फ्लैग को फाइंड आउट करना है
और जो आपका रूट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर है जो
थर्ड फ्लैग है मेरा वो रूट डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर है तब मुझे रूट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
स्विच कैसे करना
पड़ेगा रूट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर मैं स्विच
कैसे
करूंगा कैसे फाइंड आउट
करूंगा बताइए
अब आप कैसे नहीं नहीं सुडो आप कर ही नहीं
पाओगे अमन थिंक अबाउट ब्रो सोचो थोड़ा सा
कि अगर मुझे सूडो एसू कमांड परफॉर्म
करूंगा तो मुझे पॉप अप कैसे
मिलेगा पासवर्ड का पॉप अप कैसे मिलेगा यह
टर्मिनल नहीं है यह आप वेबसाइट के थ्रू एक
वल्नरेबल वेबसाइट है यस गुड मुखर्जी सो
हाइन एल
सूडो हाइन एल के थ्रू यह कमांड क्या करती
है
कि कोई भी यूजर्स होता है तो उस यूजर्स को
इस पर्टिकुलर मशीन में रूट लेवल के
कौन-कौन से प्रिविलेजेस है वह इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड करता है फॉर एपल सुड एल हान एल
इसने प्रोवाइड किया ओके डब्ड डटा यूजर्स
है वह कौन-कौन सी कमांड रन कर सकता है वह
रूट यूजर की सारी कमांड रन कर सकता है
विदाउट
पासवर्ड यह कौन सी फाइल है य डोर फाइल है
सुडोर फाइल अभी
तो उस केस में हम क्या करते हैं नस के
अंदर एक सूडो फाइल होती है ओके अब उस सुडो
फाइल में हम क्या करते हैं उस पर्टिकुलर
जो आपका यूजर्स है उसकी एंट्री बनाते हैं
और उस एंट्री के अगेंस्ट हम मेंशन करते
हैं कि ओके यह एडमिन लेवल पर क्या-क्या कर
सकता है इस पैकेज इस पैकेज को यह एडमिन
लेवल पर रन कर सकता है और काम कर सकता है
तो एक यह तरीका होता है कि एडमिन लेवल की
परमिशन ग्रांट करने का आपका किसी भी नक्
मशीन के अंदर तो यहां पर क्या है कि अभी
एडमिन लेवल के काम करने के लिए के लिए
इसको सारी परमिशन है सारे एडमिन लेवल काम
कर सकता है तो इस केस में हम क्या करेंगे
अभी
सुडो हाइन उसके बाद सुडो एलएस एक तरीका
एलएस और रूट ऐसे क्या हम लिख सकते हैं एक
तरीका होता था कि सुडो को लगा के एलएस में
करूंगा पासवर्ड पॉप अप करेगा नहीं हाफ
एलएस हाइफ रूट अगर मुझे किसी भी
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
लिस्ट आउट करने के क्या करते थे एलएस उसके
बाद फॉलो बाय डायरेक्टरी नेम ऐसे भी यूज
कर सकते थे हम बताइए यूज कर सकते थे ना तो
हिट एंटर देखिए अब इसके अंदर क्या है थर्ड
डॉटी एक्सटी एक फाइल है तो इस फ्लैग को
मुझे क्या करना है अगर एक्सेस करना है इस
फ्लैग को देखना है क्या है इस फ्लैग में
तो हम क्या करेंगे
सूडो लेस उसके बाद फिर से रूट देन उसके
अंदर क्या है थर्ड डॉट थर्ड डॉटी एक्टी और
हिट एंटर नाउ वी सक्सेसफुली थर्ड इन
ग्रेडिएंट क्या हमारा फ्लिप जूस ये हमें
तीनों तीनों फ्लैग मिल गए जिनको हम क्या
कर देंगे अभी सबमिट कर देंगे किसके अंदर
पिकल रिक के अंदर यह रहा तो नाउ वी
सक्सेसफुली गोट थ्री फ्लैग्स हमें तीनों
के तीनों फ्लैग मिल गए तो सबको पता चल गया
कि कमांड इंजेक्शन वल्नरेबल के थ्रू आप
क्या कर सकते हो किसी भी सिस्टम की मोस्ट
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन को क्या कर सकते हो
गैदर कर सकते हो उसके अंदर कोई भी आप
रिमोट कोड बेसिकली आप कोई भी रिवर्स सेल
भी यहां पर क्या कर सकते थे ऐड कर सकते थे
उसके अलावा फ आप रिवर्स कनेक्शन ले सकते
थे रिमोट कनेक्शन बना सकते थे मशीन के साथ
और किसी फाइल को डिलीट या एक्सेस कर सकते
हो क्योंकि इट इ टोटली वल्नरेबल मशीन दिस
इज अ वेरी वेरी वेरी बेसिक लैब्स जो आपको
बस्ट एक पहला तरीका था एक फर्स्ट टाइम था
कि आपको एक बिल्कुल बेसिक लेवल के लैब से
हम स्टार्ट करें क्योंकि यहां पर बिल्कुल
जूनियर टू कुछ एडवांस है जिनको आता होगा
जिनको नहीं आता होगा उनको आईडिया होगा कि
कोई भी सीटीएफ लैब्स कैसे सॉल्व करते हैं
और कैसे आपको अप्रोच बनानी है किस-किस
टाइप के यहां पर कांसेप्ट यूज हुए हैं तो
मैंने आपको बता दिया यह अप्रोच आपके पास
होनी चाहिए कि आपने कौन-कौन से स्टेप
परफॉर्म किए थे सबसे पहले आपने पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग की सर्विस वर्जन फाइंड आउट किया
उसके बाद आपने एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल के बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर की और आपके जो फोटोज
है फोटोज को आपने सेव किया स्टैग एनालिसिस
के लिए देन टेक्स्ट को पढ़ा एक गैस बना
आया उसके बाद आपने ड बस्टर डायरेक्टरी बट
फोर्स किया डायरेक्टरी फोर्स करने के बाद
आपको एक फाइल मिली लॉगइन ड पीएपी उसके बाद
यहां पर आपने ट्राई एंड ट किया सक्सेसफुली
लॉगइन किया और इस वेबसाइट के अंदर क्या थी
एक कमांड इंजेक्शन वनटी थी उसका आपने
फायदा उठाया और सक्सेसफुली आपने अपने
फ्लैग प्राप्त कर लिए और आप इस तीनों
फ्लैग को जब आप क्या करोगे यहां पर सबमिट
करोगे यह रहे पिकल रिक के अंदर व्हाट इज द
ये क्या बोल रहा है व्हाट इज द फर्स्ट
ग्रेडिएंट पिकल रीड ये रहा फर्स्ट
ग्रेडिएंट मेरा जो है ये रहा आपको सबमिट
करूं तो ये रहा दिस इज आवर फर्स्ट
ग्रेडिएंट
कॉपी कंट्रोल व और
सबमिट नाउ सेकंड ग्रेडिएंट रिक्स ऑप्शन
सेकंड ग्रेडिएंट रिक ऑप्शन क्या था हमारा
देखो ये रहा दिस इज आवर जेट
यर
कॉपी कंट्रोल व दिस इ आवर थ सेकंड फ्लैग
ना नाउ दिस इज आवर थर्ड फ्लैग फ्लिप जूस
कंट्रोल
सी कंट्रोल व नाउ रवर थर्ड फ्लैग नाउ वी
सक्सेसफुली कंप्लीट आवर
लैब्स माइंड मैप यही है ब्रो आपको क्या
करना है अभी अभी के लिए आपको मैं एक काम
करता हूं नेक्स्ट क्लास जब हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे बिफोर स्टार्टिंग आवर नेक्स्ट लैब
जो नेक्स्ट लब बिल्कुल सिमिलर होगी वह
कंप्लीट लैब मैं आपकी हेल्प से सॉल्व
करूंगा आपसे रेफरेंस लूंगा चैट सेक्शन में
उसके आधार पर हम क्या करेंगे उसको सॉल्व
करेंगे उससे पहले मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा कि इस
लैब के अंदर जो वल्नरेबल थी इस लैब के
अंदर कौन सी थी कमांड इंजेक्शन वनबिल उसको
मैं एक्सप्लेन करूंगा थ्रो स्लाइड आज आपने
बोला सर आज थोड़ा सा मैं इसको सॉल्व नहीं
करने वाला था मैं कल सॉल्व करने वाला था ब
देखिए अरे यहां पर एक मेरी लैब है यह रही
कमांड इंजेक्शन वटी क्या होती है उसको
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा कितने टाइप्स की होती है
बस यह चीज मैं आपको बताने वाला था सो दैट
कि आपको आईडिया हो जाए कमांड इंजेक्शन
वलने बिलिटी होती क्या है ओके देन उसके
बाद हम इस लैब को सॉल्व करने वाले
थे हां आप पढ़ सकते हो लिनेक्स
की तो अभी आपके लिए एज ए टास्क मैं आपको
असाइन करता हूं आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
इस लैब को सॉल्व करना है पिकल रिक को सभी
सॉल्व कर लोगे एवरीवन ये आपका टास्क है जब
भी नेक्स्ट क्लास लेंगे नेक्स्ट क्लास में
हम क्या करेंगे सेकंड लैब को स्टार्ट करने
से पहले मैं एक्सप्लेन करूंगा कमांड
इंजेक्शन वनटी होती क्या है देन आपको
एक्सप्लेन कर दूंगा कौन-कौन से स्टेप हमने
फॉलो किए थे उसके बाद थर्ड लैब को हम
स्टार्ट करेंगे लैब का लिंक या सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है इसमें लिंक क्या
प्रोवाइड करूंगा यार यह रहा सिंपली आपको
क्या करना यह रहा पिकल िक को क्या करना
आपको यह
रहा कंट्रोल सी आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं
फिर भी आपको सर्च करना है और सिंपली आप
क्या कर सकते हो एक और टास्क आप लोगों के
लिए के लिए अगर आप लोगों को पता करना है
कि कमांड इंजेक्शन वनटी होती क्या है अगर
मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन नहीं करूंगा आप चाहो
तो खुद से पढ़ना चाहते हो एक लैब है इसके
अंदर य रही इसके अंदर लैब है एक गो
बैक आप चाहो तो क्या कर सकते यहां पर सर्च
करो कमांड इंजेक्शन वलने बिलिटी उस वो
आपका टास्क है व भी आपके दो टास्क है
कमांड इंजेक्शन वनटी य रहा य रहा कमांड
इंजेक्शन वटी होती क्या है
यह प्रीमियम लैब है पर फ्री वाली नहीं है
जिसको करनी है 20 मिनट की लैब है कि कमांड
इंजेक्शन वटी होती क्या है उसको कैसे
डिस्कवर किया जाता है कैसे आपको मिलती है
उसके बाद कैसे उसको एक्सप्लोइट करना है और
उसके क्या है कि रेडिएशंस क्या है कैसे आप
बच सकते हो उसके बाद प्रैक्टिकली आपको
क्या करना है परफॉर्म करना है कि कमांड
इंजेक्शन प्रैक्टिकल परफॉर्म करना है आपको
परफॉर्म करके दे दे टोटल फाइव टास्क इससे
आपको कंप्लीट आईडिया हो जाएगा कि कंबाइंड
इंजेक्शन वटी होती क्या है कैसे काम करती
है कैसे आपको मिलती है यह भी आपके लिए
टास्क है अगर आपके पास प्रीमियम है तो आप
प्रीमियम में इसको क्या कर सकते हो सॉल्व
कर सकते
हो यह फ्री वाली अवेलेबल नहीं है फ्री
वाली तो आपको मैंने बताया पिकल
रिक तो आज की क्लास रिलेटेड कोई किसी का
कोई डाउट है
एवरीवन किसी को लगता कि सर मेरा यह सवाल
है मुझे यह पूछना
आपसे प्लीज
बताइए नहीं जरूरी नहीं है आपको क पिंक
कमांड से उसका कंप्लीट आई ट्रेस रूट कमांड
हेल्पफुल होती है ट्रेस रूट ट्रेस आरटी और
ट्रेस रूट कमांड आपको प्रोवाइड कर सकती है
कुछ
तक और कुछ
बताइए किसे कोई सवाल रिलेटेड टू
क्लास नहीं यह बग बाउंट क्लास नहीं
यार दिस इज अ पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
बग बाउंट टिप यहां पर नहीं मिलेगी
आपको नहीं कई बार शुभम आपको क्या होता है
कि आपको जो अनफॉलो लिंक्स होते हैं तो आप
उनको भी क्या करते हो जब आप विजिट करते तो
आप फिर भी उसको एक्सेस नहीं कर पाते आप
एसबीआई की या फेसबुक की क्या करोगे रोबट
फाइल को देखिए और अनफॉलो जो डिस अलाउ है
डिसला को विजिट कर करके देखिए हर एक का तो
आप यूज इट नहीं कर पाते क्योंकि उनके लिए
कंडीशंस होती है कि वो पर्टिकुलर
डायरेक्टरी या पर्टिकुलर पेज को लोग वो
करने के लिए एक्सेस करने के लिए आपको यह
कंडीशन फुलफिल करनी पड़े मतलब आपको लॉगिन
होने चाहिए एक वैलिड कंडीशन के साथ तो
नहीं कर पाओगे एक्सेस है ना
भा क्या सिस्टम हैकिंग
बताइए किसी का कोई सवाल जवाब या क्लास को
एंड
करें ओके किसी का अगर आपका खुद का कोई
डाउट लगता है तो आपको क्या करना चाहिए कि
आपको सिंपली हमारे कमेंट सेक्शन में अपने
डाउट को पूछ लेना है तो मैं आपको डाउट
एक्सप्लेन कर दूंगा वहीं पर या अदर वाइज
नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपको एक्सप्लेन कर
दूंगा तो ओके बाय बाय टेक केयर
एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेक्शन जल्दी
मिलेंगे नेक्स्ट सेशन में नई लैब के साथ
तब तक के लिए आपके टास्क कंप्लीट कीजिए
आपको दो टास्क दिए हैं अगर आपके पास
प्रीमियम नहीं है तो आप सेकंड वाले टास्क
को स्किप कर सकते हो लेकिन जो फ्री फ्री
वाली जो लैब है आपकी पिकल रिक आप इसको
क्या कर सकते हो एक्सप्लेन कर सकते हो
आपको इसको हैक करना है इसके अंदर छुपे तीन
फ्लैग को सबमिट करना है उसके बाद टेक
स्क्रीनशॉट और जो जो आपने स्टेप फॉलो किए
जो जो टेक्निक्स टैक्टिक्स आपने फॉलो की
वह सारी एक्सलेन के साथ आपको क्या करना है
लिंक दिन पेज पर हमें पोस्ट करना है और
मुझे और डेफ अकेडमी को क्या करना है टैक
करना है तो देखते हैं कितने लोग सॉल्व
करते हैं सॉल्व करने के बाद कितने लोग
स्क्रीनशॉट अटैच करते हैं अब मुझे नहीं
लगता ज्यादा लोग करने वाले हैं ओके थैंक
यू बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन गुड नाइट